Dr Dan anxiously paced in his cell it
was the only way he'd been able to
occupy himself for the past six months
save for pouring through files and when
he was lucky being able to oversee
another failed termination attempt he
only stopped pacing when for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment that horrible creature that he'd
thrown away his life for a feudal shot
at killing perhaps the whole thing had
been a Fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employee
of the SCP Foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like scp-106 the nightmarish old man and
scp-352 Baba Yaga in containment cells
and there was no plans to terminate
either of them they weren't the global
occult Coalition for 343's sake why did
Dr Dan even want to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp-096 was leaked onto
the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seated in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp-096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp-096's face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disparate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as
scp-096 went on its bloody Rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do the
purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing Mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong where refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it what
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096 he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles it was why
he needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain Mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regret but
it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate
scp-096 he was discovering that he
lacked another important factor the
capability they tried incinerating it
exposing it to massive amounts of
radiation exposing it to an insane
degree of kinetic trauma the equivalent
of being hit by an out of control bullet
train they tested every kind of
experimental off the books Weaponry that
they had access to through various
research projects proton blasts lasers
high intensity energy beams nothing even
when they fried off every scrap of Flesh
on the mount sister's body its
unbreakable skeletons still remained and
in what seemed like no time at all it'd
be back in Action its very existence
seemed to mock him a guard opened his
cell door staring disdainfully at the
disgraced researcher that same guard had
slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier one of his friends had
apparently been killed in the legendary
096 Containment Breach that set this
whole sword thing in motion up an atom
scumbag he sat in the gruff Surly voice
training a handgun on the doctor he knew
wouldn't fight back they need you in
test chamber 6. Dr Dan allowed himself a
small grin imperceptible to the guard
who clearly hated his guts they'd
approved his 096 vs 682 cross test
marvelous how marvelous to all the
others it would seem like just one more
entry in the long line of 682 cross
tests he thought it Darkly funny in his
eyes the foundation had no hope of ever
killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe scp-682
would hold the secret to actually
killing off his Nemesis within 30 hours
Dr Dan had his disappointing answer both
anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other and Dr Dan did take
a kind of sick Amusement in the mental
trauma that scp-682 had induced in 096
But ultimately it was all for nothing
682 had skin 096 alive and melted off
its flesh with acid but once again that
indestructible skeleton stood firm this
had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident the 27th failed
termination attempt Dr Dan mentally
corrected himself
096's skeleton kept defeating them even
their most Ardent attempts to penetrate
the bones and destroy the creature
within had failed during a previous
attempt they tried to access the brain
by putting a diamond hard drill into its
eye sockets of course it was the drill
that actually broke much to Dr Dan's
seemingly tireless frustration needless
to say in the debriefing interview with
Dr Carver a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague he
wasn't in High Spirits if he managed to
kill this thing then he would always be
the hero who made a terrible sacrifice
in order to save many more lives if he
didn't kill 096 he was little more than
the monster who murdered all those
innocent people for nothing though you'd
never hear him say it out loud if it
wasn't for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him
SCP-173 the sculpture a site 19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993 one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the Shy Guy's
vertebrae once his proposed proposal was
greenlit for initial testing Dr Dan
arranged for the shy guy with a bag over
his head of course to be brought into a
testing chamber with the ever stoic
SCP-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr
Dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy Crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight zero nine six
doubled over at an unnatural angle its
spine snapped between the fourth and
fifth vertebrae spinal fluid leaking
down the creature's flank that freaky
little sculpture had done it it had
actually damaged the Integrity of the
Shy Guy's skeleton it was at that moment
that Dr Dan knew he could kill this
thing admittedly there was a Containment
Breach shortly after that when the bag
slipped off of 096's head can it charge
through the nearby steel wall killing
multiple people before being subdued and
re-contained but when it comes to
projects involving Dr Dan a mere handful
of innocent people being killed sits
comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error a day later Dr Dan was standing
before a crowded boardroom with agents
researchers and even a few members of
the o5 council in attendance he
explained his findings to them and the
fact that even more importantly they may
have a way to bring The Wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion Dr Dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe Zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber one group kept
173 isolated with their stairs the other
headed by Dr Dan prepared the acid
injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096's spine as the acid was pumped by
the gallon into 096's Bones the creature
let out the most horrifying whale it
kicked and bucked as more acid was
pumped in melting those indestructible
Bones from within the creature even
began to vomit acid as it panicked
melting the bag off of its own head some
panicked and averted their gaze Dr Dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure relation heading one had
he actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and treat they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won
scp-999 also known as the Tickle Monster
it's one of the most adorable beloved
and undeniably wholesome anomalies ever
to exist in the SCP foundation's
Containment facilities its mere presence
can cause joy and comfort cure
depression and other mental illnesses
and even sometimes cause violent and
unpredictable creatures to really mellow
out if you're a fan of this channel
chances are that you're a big fan of
scp-9992 but that doesn't mean everyone
is on board as we all know there are
plenty of entities and groups in the SCP
universe that are downright evil and as
a result would love to see this little
blob of pure joy Crush to a pulp or
sacrifice to a cosmic horror but you
can't ever underestimate wait a second
is that a Containment Breach alarm all
Foundation staff members report to the
affected cell immediately it looks like
an scps escape containment in this now
in our world that's right scp-999 has
broken out of SCP Foundation control and
now you can finally have a tickle
monster of your very own in plush form
this super adorable plush from SCP swag
is 11 inches of huggable squeezable joy
and now that the Tickle Monster is out
of containment you can bring it into
your own home tickle monster plushies
are available for pre-order now and all
orders made in the next 10 days also get
a special limited first edition card
worldwide shipping is also available so
go to scpswag.com right now and
pre-order your own Tickle Monster and
let us know in the comments what SCP
anomalies you want to see in plush form
next but as we were saying you can't
ever underestimate scp-999 not only is
it tickled scp-682 into submission there
are also certain theories floating
around the foundation that it will one
day grow so powerful its forces of pure
goodness and joy can overthrow the
Scarlet King himself
that's why today we're throwing the
Tickle Monster into a kind of Royal
Rumble with all the baddest dudes the
foundation has ever encountered and
we're going to give our theories on how
scp-999 might somehow find the good and
even the blackest of Hearts first
scp-096 the shy guy a killing machine so
brutal direct and opaque in its motives
but some have even questioned whether it
actually has sentience however we'd
personally stick our claim that it does
when a photo of this Savage Beast was
taken with scp-978 the desire camera a
camera that shows the deepest desire of
its subjects it revealed that the shy
guy secretly just had the desire to
disappear not only does this suggest
that the monster may not actually like
killing people but the very idea that it
can have a desire also implies some
level of intelligence but how would
scp-999 enter the mix well we know that
096 is an anxious creature it spends the
majority of its time just pacing itself
and when someone sees its face it begins
sobbing uncontrollably before entering
its rage state does this sound like a
happy entity to you if the shy guy
encountered 999 at its full joy-giving
power we'd personally think that it
might finally chill out a little perhaps
it'd take a moment to breathe and
contemplate life a little more maybe it
would wonder why it's so ashamed of its
face and feels the need to hunt down and
kill anyone who sees it after all there
are much uglier anomalies like
scp-106 he's the next Monster to join
this weird wild cage match against
scp-999 while 096 is violent 106 is
downright malevolent he's not just
sentient but extremely intelligent the
old man loves causing pain and suffering
for his own perverse pleasure just as
much as Heavy Hitters like scp-682 so
surely 999 would have its work cut out
for it here well not necessary early
there are two leading theories about who
106 actually is one being the Scranton
Theory and the other the Corporal
Lawrence Theory the first dictates that
106 is the result of Dr Robert Scranton
physically and mentally transformed by
his time in scp-3001 the terrifying red
reality the second theory was that he
was a World War one soldier known as
Corporal Lawrence whose anomalous
encounter in the trenches turned him
into the Beast he is today in either
case he's a man shaped by pain an
anomalous trauma much like 096 the
desire camera revealed an insight into
106's mind his greatest desire consists
of him walking across a field towards an
old house where an old woman smiles and
waits for him many believe this old
woman to be his estranged wife perhaps
an encounter with scp-9999 would cause
106's sadism to Abate reminding him of
the humanity he once had maybe he'd
become a kindly old man in the aftermath
who prefers Werther's Originals to
violence and spinning long rambling
Yarns about the war rather than chasing
people around his terrifying pocket
Dimension it's a thought so sweet it
could almost make you sick thankfully
one of our favorite doctors is next on
the list specifically the plague doctor
scp-049 while he definitely isn't as
dangerous or malicious as either of his
predecessors 049 has racked up quite a
body count in his hundreds of years of
operations he sees pestilence everywhere
he goes except within and can kill with
a mere touch however his deadly touch
only seems to apply to non-anomalous
animals and humans not other anomalies
so he definitely couldn't harm 999 and
the Tickle Monster conversely could
definitely touch him back while the
plague doctor is the serious type he
might not be able to keep his bedside
manner after a serious tickling and we'd
be more than willing to hedge our bets
on him having the laugh of an Angel
while 049 may have folded in the face of
999's tickling wrath our next contestant
is as solid as a rock well technically
as solid as concrete that's because its
SCP-173 also known as the sculpture or
the peanut it shows no emotions and
murders anything that blinks in its
Presence by snapping its neck but 999
doesn't even have bones let alone a neck
so SCP-173 has nothing with which to
threaten this happy little blob and what
about scp-9999's counter-offensive if
the Tickle Monster got its slime all
over SCP-173 it might finally reform
this statuesque serial killer through
prolonged exposure maybe after that 173
will finally give relaxing neck massages
rather than snapping them but while the
sculpture may be intimidating it's
nothing compared to an unkillable Mass
murdering blade Master right of course
we're talking about scp-076
also known as able no matter how many
times he gets put down he keeps coming
back with unparalleled skills in
physical combat and the ability to pull
huge blades out of thin air he also
appears to be fueled by pure Unstoppable
rage so how on Earth could our adorable
little Tickle Monster possibly go
toe-to-toe with a swordsman who cuts
through Elite Mobile task force soldiers
like a hot knife through a d-class much
like scp-106 it seems like a lot of
Abel's rage is rooted in a deep pain
caused by his past if he truly is the
biblical able it's likely that his rage
stems from being the very first murder
victim betrayed and killed by his
brother Kane now known as
scp-073 spending time with scp-9999
might finally calm him down enough to
actually work through some of these
issues and come to a sense of closure
maybe with scp-9999 at his side Abel
could attend some therapy sessions with
Foundation psychologists and until he
finally felt as though he'd move past
his murderous urges perhaps even working
up to family counseling with Kane he
could then re-enter society and reapply
his expert knife skills and become a
Bobby Flay style celebrity chef except
one who could actually Flay you if you
got on his bad side but let's talk about
an SCP that's frankly dangerous to even
discuss I am of course referring to
scp-2521 okay great I'm not dead
wonderful let's carry on
2521 is attracted to any information
about it written or spoken it will
immediately appear upon the creation of
this information and steal either the
information itself or the person
disseminating it in the case of verbal
words if someone were to pass scp-999 a
fact sheet about
scp-2521 it would inevitably manifest
and prepare to throw down but perhaps
the positive influence of scp-999 would
change
scp-2521's tune rather than obsessively
stealing information about itself the
being May instead finally open up and
speak about itself we might even learn
some interesting things like the fact it
used to have a bowling team with scp-106
and
scp-049 he also loves knitting
foreign
[Music]
now how about we go for something a
little closer to human please
scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal a huge
ogre-like humanoid that has a penchant
for pathological lies and also devouring
human heads and while the rest of the
body on and well the rest of the body
too if he's worked up enough of an
appetite he's super strong and has a
hide so thick that seemingly no weapon
can penetrate it how could a CP 999
possibly go around with a behemoth like
this lucky for 999 fernan has an
extremely cheerful temperament if a
potential victim can keep him amused
often listening and playing along with
his elaborate fantasies it massively
increases their chance of survival and
considering scp-9999 is literally a good
vibes machine there's a good chance that
it'd keep Ferdinand so amused that the
thought of getting hangry wouldn't even
cross his mind once again little scp-999
takes home the W but what about a real
sadist a truly heartless monster whose
commitment to focused endless cruelty is
genuinely unparalleled we're talking
about the being from
scp-3999 this terrifyingly powerful
reality warper hasn't racked up scores
of victims because it prefers the
quality of suffering over quantity it'll
select a single victim trap them in
their own personal hell and spend a
literal eternity conceiving every
possible torture and torment to break
the spirit and body of the victim never
giving them the luxury of death however
if an entity could turn the tables and
break the spirit of scp-39999 it would
be
scp-9999 picture it thousands of years
where the monster tries everything it
can to break the tickle Monster's Spirit
only to find its own spirit being broken
as scp-999 doesn't succumb to any of it
and continues to project love and
kindness throughout could you imagine
anything more frustrating for a creature
like 39.99 eventually it would probably
get so frustrated that it would let 999
go and find some hapless Foundation
researcher to torture instead going up
against a single anomalous being
regardless of its power is one thing but
taking on an entire group is another
challenge for scp-999 what if 999 became
trapped in scp-3008 the endless Ikea
surrounded by the deadly staff in the
middle of the night our theory is that
the positive presence of scp-999 would
really help the nightmarish malformed
staff of this accursed Ikea turned their
lives around and start creating a more
positive work environment around the
store rather than trying to chase
survivors trapped inside the store and
beat them to death they would instead
help them find the ideal furniture for
enhancing their lifestyle if they ever
managed to escape the building 999 would
help them go from horrifying to helpful
in no time it'd be so nice in there that
the survivors wouldn't even want to
leave but what about groups of Interest
let's say the chaos Insurgency has
broken into a containment site in
another one of its classic raids against
the foundation would a group of elite
chaos Insurgency operatives be able to
take down the Tickle Monster we think
not while these anomaly stealing
militants may be hardcore compared to
your average Joe they're nowhere near as
hateful or irredeemable as the likes of
682 or 106. chances are if they've spent
any amount of time around 999 they'd
experience a sudden sense of mellowness
and begin to rethink of their poor life
choices but what about the GOC those
government Stooges obsessed with killing
any anomaly they can get their hands on
personally we theorize that a run-in
with scp-999 and the immensely positive
feelings it causes would cause them to
reevaluate their entire philosophy on
the anomalies they encounter and lead
them to restructure their entire
organization from the ground up perhaps
they'd even promote scp-9999 to the
position of under Secretary General and
perhaps even change the meaning of the
group's acronym to givers of Cuddles in
honor of their new leader and direction
we can dream right but let's end this
dream with a nightmare the Scarlet King
the most dangerous being in the entire
Multiverse who is also strongly believed
to be
scp-9999's real father hmm awkward can
ultimate Goods someday defeat ultimate
Evil according to ancient dived
prophecies a terrifying historical
culture that worshiped the Scarlet King
yes it can if given the time and
nurturing it needs to reach full power
how exactly would that battle play out
well it's difficult to even theorize but
chances are it'd be a battle of truly
biblical proportions and if ever the
Scarlet King did breach our Dimension
it's safe to say that you'd want your
own little scp-999 close at hand and now
you can go to scpswag.com and pre-order
a tickle Monster Plush of your very own
it doesn't even need any anomalous
powers to bring you a ridiculous amount
of Joy orders placed in the next 10 days
get a special limited first edition card
so don't wait get yours now before
they're all gone but start off with a
difficult question how do you define
reality what is truly real is it simply
a case of what we can see if something
is known as fact and can be proven to
exist does this make it real is reality
just the world around us or is there
something more the goal of these
questions isn't to make you question
every part of the world around you or to
question whether or not we are all
living in a computer simulation no
you're asked this to help you understand
reality because first of all we aren't
living in a simulation we're living in a
sitcom there is a wide-ranging debate on
what the most powerful and dangerous
scps ever encountered are but there is
no denying the ever-present danger of
scp-3812 this cutter class entity is
regarded as highly aggressive by the o5
council especially as it has only ever
been partially contained never fully the
true scope of its abilities is currently
unknown and any available information on
scp-3812 is kept classified and secure
by the foundation needless to say this
entity poses a direct threat not only to
the SCP Foundation but to the very
fabric of reality itself contained
within the file for scp-3812 is an
excerpt from an article by one Dr Robert
Scranton titled super session and the
echelon of reality in this article Dr
Scranton posits a theory about the
nature of reality and understanding him
is the first step towards understanding
scp-3812 his recursive stack theory
states that there are different layers
to reality but also that no single
universe is real an easy way to think of
it is to imagine a sitcom any sitcom you
can Envision will do between us and the
fictional world of a sitcom there are
multiple observable stacked universes
firstly our universe the real world as
we experience it forms the Baseline so
imagine this sitting at the top of the
stack next down in the stack comes the
sitcom a fictional Universe filled with
characters which fits below r our
universe then think of what is fiction
within the fiction of the sitcom perhaps
another television show one that only
exists in the world of the sitcom but
not in our own this is the recursive
stack infinitely layered universes and
it is crucial you can Envision and
remember this model DR Scranton's Theory
suggests that any Universe even our own
could potentially exist as a fictional
narrative within another wider Universe
this wider Universe in which ours is a
fiction could also itself be a narrative
within an even wider Universe stacked
above it and so on it's interesting to
picture reality this way isn't it in
fact I'm willing to bet that you're
wondering maybe there's a universe above
ours or even one above that with the
universe right at the top of the stack
be the truly real world and what if you
could travel between each stacked
reality if you're asking any of those
questions then congratulations you sound
exactly like SCP
scp-3812 was previously known as Sam
Howell while little is known about his
life Sam was as far as anyone knew
regarded as a fairly ordinary human
being until his death in 1996 shortly
after which Sam Rose from his grave and
disappeared it is unknown whether
scp-3812 simply imitated the form of Sam
Howell or if they are one and the same
as this entity has been known to have
the ability to change forms at will
making it hard for the foundation to
track it it does usually maintain a
humanoid appearance however this has
deteriorated somewhat over numerous
decades by now you may have already
gathered that the extent of
scp-3812's abilities don't end at
shape-shifting this SCP is a powerful
aggressive reality altering entity cast
your mind back to the recursive stack
scp-3812 is able to travel upwards
through these stacked universes creating
Untold chaos using its plethora of world
bending abilities as far as the SCP
Foundation can tell 3812's sole
intention is to become an omnipotent
Force existing above any and all
possible universes in other words the
top of the stack aside from the ability
to change shape
scp-3812s control and alteration of a
reality around it is achieved by its
long list of latent abilities this
entity is capable of Feats far beyond
that of normal humans such as
teleportation telekinesis and telepathy
however scp-3812 is also able to
directly manipulate any and all aspects
of reality it can influence an alter
observable forces around us for example
the manipulation of matter energy
weather and even gravity and other laws
of physics as we know them but the
creature can also warp reality on
further levels it's able to erase people
objects or even Concepts to the point
where human beings lose virtually all
memory of them with the danger that an
entity this powerful poses to our
reality it's not surprising that the SCP
Foundation would attempt to nullify its
abilities one attempt by the foundation
involved another unknown SCP which
created an anti-metaphysical field this
was done in the hopes that it would
strip
scp-3812 of its reality warping
abilities however the entity was unfazed
the containment attempt failed and the
remains of the unknown SCP instead
resulted in the creation of
scp-239 as for the scp-3812 entities own
origin that is still largely unknown but
there does exist a message on a secure
server in the SCP foundation's o5
command seemingly from another entity
belonging to a reality stacked higher
above our own that appears to have
created a reality much further down one
that scp-3812 inhabited and now it seems
that scp-3812 is climbing up the stack
there is a trade-off of sorts to the
abundance of powers
scp-3812 possesses The Entity is in an
almost constant state of Ascension
through different stacked universes
climbing higher and higher believing
every reality beneath it to be a fiction
the creature has developed multiple
severe mental conditions that seem to be
a direct result of overexposure to
different layers of reality this
includes an advanced form of enigman
theater schizophrenia complex which
often manifests in extreme symptoms
within the creature
scp-3812 has been known to suffer from
paranoia dysphoria depression and
inability to control its emotions as
well as hearing voices seeing things
that do not exist and possessing
multiple personalities while the
creature is usually aimless
scp-3812 has been known to have random
outbursts that can cause anomalies
within local space and time but thanks
to it experiencing so many different
layers of reality traveling upwards
through what it perceives to be
fictional universes
scp-3812 displays difficulty in
separating what is real and what is
imagined in fact reality and fiction
have become one in the same to scp-3812
because as far as it is concerned they
literally are the same each new reality
it inhabits is just fiction for the
reality stacked above it so then how are
we supposed to contain or neutralize
such a powerful reality altering
creature that cannot distinguish between
what is real and what is fictional the
foundation knows that its own procedures
to keep scp-3812 contained would be
ineffective this entity by its nature
cannot be contained any attempt to keep
it locked away would easily be undone by
any one of its numerous powers to warp
reality locking it in a cement box at
the bottom of the ocean would be
pointless it could teleport out or turn
its cell into nothing but dust putting
it in a vat of acid to endlessly burn it
would just result in it turning that
acid to harmless water or air
scp-3812 can manipulate events
throughout time and so it could easily
prevent itself from ever being contained
it is even possible that any individuals
even Foundation staff who may have
previously tried to lock the creature up
now no longer exists thanks to
scp-3812's abilities and there would be
no way to determine this since we
wouldn't be able to remember that the
person had ever been in our reality the
foundation's best hope is to keep
scp-3812 where it is and hope it remains
docile if they are able to keep it away
from large population centers then the
risk of 3812 having any sort of psychic
influence over citizens or warping
reality and causing the deaths of
millions or even billions is at least
reduced but of course it is never fully
gone on at least one occasion
scp-3812 has caused a truly catastrophic
event for some reason
scp-3812 decided to turn itself into a
star spinning endlessly and it did so
numerous anomalous occurrences took
place across the world most notably
scp-3812 caused the foundation's nuclear
warheads to detonate spreading harmful
radioactive material into the atmosphere
Additionally the population of New
Zealand began to sporadically disappear
and reappear looping back and forth
between existence and non-existence for
a period of around five hours it was
during this world-ending scenario that
scp-3812 still at the center of its star
form was recorded ranting its split
personalities arguing one of the
creature's personalities claimed it was
unmaking the world as an act of revenge
against someone it stated that it
believed existence is a joke The
Narrative abandoned us to be miserable
and we are breaking the narrative its
other half mentioned another entity
known only as Ben and seemed to imply
that this entity was responsible for
scp-3812's create nation in a reality
stacked above this one according to the
more rational of 3812's two halves this
Ben entity deemed us unfit to rest
peacefully to slip into the darkness
quietly he made a game of us it then
went on to convince this other half that
destroying this reality just a slight
Bend would be pointless there would
always be another stacked on top
infinitely so why does this narrative
mean anything to you it asked it is one
of an eternity to others it is not
special it is not particular the two
sides of scp-3812 argued with each other
one wanting to destroy all of reality to
spite Ben driven mad by witnessing
trillions upon trillions of universes
stacked atop each other the other half
of 3812 saw peace for itself ascending
above these infinitely stacked universes
finally reaching the top and becoming
free not a god a star rising in the East
Rising away from this all until we are a
Little More Than A Memory of a song it
will be lonely the other half of the
creature replied We'll have each other
scp-3812's other personality said I'm
afraid said the one intent on
destruction I am too the other reassured
it but that is no reason to destroy this
narrative eventually
scp-3812's personalities reached
agreement they both left the narrative
they were currently in presumably
traveling upwards to one stacked above
our own while simultaneously remaining
in this universe still a danger let go
of this world let him rewrite it back to
what it was we aren't part of this
anymore shortly after this event reality
shifted once more and the entire world
reverted back to how it had been before
records of the end of the world scenario
that had occurred were retained by
high-level administrators and the o5
council perhaps as a reminder of the
destructive capabilities of the creature
a warning of its potential to change the
this reality and any stacked below or
above it fortunately since this incident
scp-3812 has remained in its docile
aimless State no longer actively hostile
to anyone that approaches it it has kept
its amorphous star-like shape and is
still very much able to create
disruptions and anomalies in reality
despite keeping scp-3812 constantly
monitored at its current location in the
South Pacific Ocean the SCP Foundation
knows that at any time this entity could
trigger yet another Global catastrophe
causing massive damage to planet Earth
its population and beyond that tearing
our reality itself asunder so we all
just better hope our narrative remains
worthwhile to
scp-3812's better half it all started in
1983 with reports of human trafficking
in the heart of Sin City the FBI had
gotten word of a potential trafficking
ring operating out of an abandoned
department store in Los Vegas Nevada and
immediately began organizing a secret
raid on the building while they would
indeed encounter something horrifying
within that abandoned department store
it wasn't criminals or human trafficking
in fact it wasn't human at all this is
the horrifying story of SCP 847 after
weeks of planning the raid on the
department store was conducted in the
dead of night agents covered all the
exits and entrances and a helicopter was
stationed nearby in case anyone
attempted to run it should have been a
perfect trap but things never go as
planned when you don't know what you're
dealing with the agents breached the
door and began searching the darkened
building it didn't appear that there was
any power so the traffickers must have
had great night vision and high
tolerance for creepy locales agents soon
heard a faint humming sound coming from
below a generator it must be located in
the basement and be the Hub of this
criminal Enterprise readying themselves
for whatever they were about find the
agents descended into the basement as
they moved deeper into the building they
found that lighting rigs had been set up
they must be getting closer to something
but that something was still a mystery a
senior FBI special agent was leading the
charge his pistol drawn and ready it was
quiet too quiet did the traffickers
already realize they were coming and
clear out he was ready to consider this
bus to bust when he heard a quiet
muelling in the distance a persistent
whining whimper that was undeniably
human he gave the signal to his fellow
agents to follow the noise they
proceeded forward towards the pain
sounds and found themselves in a wide
well-lit room filled with department
store mannequins all were broken to some
degree some were totally smashed to
Pieces some were chained to walls and
locked in cages others were wrapped in
plastic the agent wondered whether this
was some kind of Twisted junk or a
messed up avant-garde art piece that's
when noticed her a single Crouch figure
in the distance hunched over and
whimpering in a darkened corner of the
room near a full-length mirror he
couldn't fully make her out but he got
the sense that something was wrong she
was injured bent over was she even
missing an arm just one of these
monsters done to this woman he whispered
a request for backup Into His Radio and
pushed on when he got within 50 meters
of this strange woman her demeanor
changed entirely she jerked around her
movements forced erratic and painful
looking the woman stared directly into
the agent's eyes and began hobbling
towards him occasionally stopping to
strike a pose as if modeling during a
photo shoot just then the agent made a
horrifying realization this thing moving
towards them wasn't a woman at all it
was a living mannequin as she got closer
though he realized that the mannequin's
broken left forearm had been carved into
a large shiv a female Junior FBI agent
had been one of the many to pour into
the room when the raid leader had
radioed for backup the second she
entered the 50 meter range of this
strange mannequin everything changed in
an instant its eyes and mouth began
dripping with a thick viscous resin its
whimpering gasp suddenly became vicious
ear splitting screeches and it turned
its gaze from the senior FBI agent who
was now focused on the junior agent who
had just entered the room and broke into
a terrifying run straight towards her
the mannequin moved with a violent
single-minded purpose other agents began
firing but it was running freakishly
fast and easily dodged most of the
bullets the few that actually had seemed
to do nothing to slow the creature down
it Shrugged off the damage and kept
running with a great leap it landed on
the terrified Junior agent and began
jabbing her with its bladed arm the
other agents stopped firing fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague
during the Panic the mannequin was
ruthless clawing and stabbing with
strange resin leaking out of its every
orifice terrified and unable to reach
her gun the agent remembered her
training she reached into her belt and
grabbed her stun gun jamming the two
probes up against the creature's chest
and giving it 30 000 volts the creature
spasmed fell backwards and collapsed in
a heap on the ground Frozen this was the
first recorded encounter with
scp-847 a violent living mannequin with
a serious problem with women this
terrifying report was passed up the
chain of command until it landed on the
desk of a foundation agent working in
the FBI the foundation quickly swooped
in and claimed the mannequin delivered
necessary amnesic treatment to all who'd
witnessed it and closely observed the
female Junior FBI agent's recovery in a
private hospital with Foundation ties as
it turns out they were right to do so as
the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate while the wound she'd suffered at
the hands of scp-847 didn't appear fatal
the fact that the mannequin anomalous
resin excretions entered the open wound
changed everything several hours after
being committed the junior agent began
complaining of Lynn's stiffness and
difficulty moving this quickly developed
into full paralysis over time her skin
and internal organs began to harden
until the process dubbed plastination
came to a gruesome end the junior agent
wasn't just dead she had been
transformed into a mannequin Foundation
researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization this means that
all the other Broken Mannequins found
with scp-847 were likely once living
humans attacked and transformed by the
anomaly now a source for new harvested
body parts now safely interred as a
foundation containment facility though
the real tests on scp-847 to determine
its behavior and physical attributes
could begin the most important detail
about
scp-847 is that it's a aggression is
exclusively directed towards women as
opposed to when it encounters men and
its instincts are more self-destructive
through a series of tests and
observations researchers have been able
to pin down three different distinct
patterns of behavior for
scp-847 pattern Z behaviors occur when
there are no humans standing within 50
meters of
scp-847 the mannequin will seek out a
full-length mirror and pose in front of
it much like a department store
mannequin attempting to show off its
clothes it remains largely inanimate
during these periods and will very
occasionally use a finger or whatever
appendage is available given its habit
for self-mutilation to scratch messages
on nearby surfaces pattern y Behavior
occurs when male humans with XY
chromosomes enter a 50 meter radius
around
scp-847 just like its reaction to the
male FBI agents who founded 847 will
initially emit vocalizations that seem
whimpering gasps before making eye
contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject it will
then remain static and allow the male
subject to pose its body however after
the male subject leaves the area 847
will enter a state of considerable
distress and begin removing or
shattering parts of its body the
foundation has found that the parts
removed or shattered are often
consistent with parts that the male
subjects found displeasing during
interactions showing a masochistic
desire to impress these parts are then
harvested back from plastinated victims
which brings us to the most dangerous of
Its Behavior patterns pattern X
behaviors occur when female humans enter
a 50 meter radius around the creature
847 will immediately become brutally
aggressive switching its noises from
whimpers to violent screeches and growls
847 experiences enhance physical
capabilities during pattern X states its
speed has been measured at 45 kilometers
per hour making it as fast as the
legendary
scp-096 it's also been shown to exhibit
extreme physical strength it's during
this pattern of behavior that it begins
excreting its deadly resin which has
been proven to only be dangerous to
women in these states the only thing
capable of reliably pacifying the being
is a powerful electric shock the shock
causes the creatures resin to harden
temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly five minutes other Conventional
Weapons and damage has no meaningful
effect on
scp-847 after a number of incidents that
had sad and violent endings the
foundation Ethics Committee forbade the
use of female d-class Personnel in
scp-847 testing when it came to female
subjects 847 always slipped into a state
of extreme aggression so instead the
foundation began testing with male
subjects in hopes a better understanding
the Dynamics between human males and SCP
847 various misogynistic d-class males
were introduced into the containment
chamber which was modeled to look like a
bedroom for the purposes of Behavioral
study each one either during or after
their interaction with scp-847 was told
to comment on some aspect they felt
dissatisfied with the mannequin
shattered its own chest after hearing it
described as being out of proportion
after another d-class called its nose
ugly the mannequin broke it off after
another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability
to drink it tore out its hair and liver
all parts were replaced after the
experiments things took their most
violent and upsetting term yet with the
introduction of
d-7294 a lot of the time d-class
Personnel are considered to be as
Anonymous as they are expendable but
d-7294 is an exception before becoming
d-class he was a successful cello
teacher who brutally murdered one of his
teenage students and her mother he
typically employed in tests when the
foundation wishes to see interactions
between anomalies and humans with
confirmed Psychopathic personalities
during his interaction with scp-847 he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin
he forced it into uncomfortable poses
and even snapped off one of its fingers
before being dragged from the room by
Foundation guards in the following
debrief he further berated the mannequin
as useless and lousy at its job of being
controlled by him in response 847
extracted its own brains eyes and
clavicle before shattering its own hands
in dismay so why does 847 behave this
way while it may appear monstrous it
seems that the reason scp-847 does what
it does is All Too Human it hurts women
because it itself is hurting and it's
willing to hurt itself even more for the
approval of the objects of its desire as
a result it's an anomaly trapped in an
endless cycle of pain and violence
perhaps one day it'll be able to free
itself from the loop but that day is
unlikely to come for this murderous
mannequin anytime soon some things are
Best Kept contained after all this is
the founding principle behind the SCP
Foundation themselves to secure and
contain the most dangerous anomalies in
order to protect human lives but within
the foundation itself are things which
should never be uncovered secrets that
must never be told secured behind
multiple layers of a containment like
the Seven Seals of Revelation is a
threat so high level in its nature that
it can't even be given a class
scp-5999 but in order to truly
understand this late series SCP we have
to go all the way back to one of the
earliest anyone looking for scp-001 will
quickly realize that there are several
different entities and anomalies that
share this designation many reasons have
been given for this classification core
perhaps they were all discovered in the
early days of the foundation before the
current numbering system was introduced
others have suggested that many
different
scp-001s are an intentional misdirection
by the foundation to keep the nature of
the true first SCP a closely guarded
secret one of the many entities and the
one we'll be referring to as scp-001 to
understand
scp-59999 is otherwise known as the
database information about the database
is kept a secret to the entire SCP
Foundation apart from the overseer
Council the reason behind this well that
would be because this scp-001 contains
details of the very nature of the
foundation itself including its creation
not how the organization was founded
mind you how it was created and by whom
we're about to break the most powerful
layer of containment of all the fourth
wall you see to URI the SCP foundation
and its vast catalog of user-generated
articles on the creative and the creepy
are nothing more than a source of
entertainment it can be fun to study the
lore and the nuances of different scps
appreciating the imagination and hard
work that the authors put into writing
them it can even Inspire us fuel our own
written Endeavors whether that takes the
form of fan fiction independent stories
original scps or even a YouTube series
but when all is said and done we all
know that the SCP Foundation is
fictional and they know it too piece
together from various fragments of
information within their own archives
the database contains everything the
foundation knows about the real world
authors of the SCP Wiki just like we
told you it's time to weigh a fawn
farewell to the fourth wall the
metaphorical barrier that separates what
we know to be real from what we know to
be purely fiction the fact that they
exist in this fictional capacity is
something the overseer Council helps to
hide from the rest of the foundation's
Personnel but they also have plans in
mind for the SCP Wiki writers
responsible for creating them and
expanding the roster of anomalies they
keep contained the SCP Wiki entry on
scp-001 the database closes with a
proposal a plan from the o5 council to
reach the Wiki's authors in the real
world through memetic kill agents that
will put them to sleep and then kill
them with that important background
context in mind now let's go all the way
back to the other end of the SCP Wiki
and take a look at
scp-59999 when first accessing the file
you the reader will notice a few format
differences between this entry and
others within the SCP archive each
section of scp-59999 is hidden behind an
encryption and accessing these will
reveal the different levels of this
entry remember how we mentioned the
Seven Seals of Revelation at the start
of this video that wasn't a coincidence
in the Bible's book Book of Revelation
there are seven symbolic seals securing
a book that John of Panama saw in his
vision of the Apocalypse when these
Seven Seals are broken and the book is
opened this symbolizes the second coming
of the Messiah and marks the beginning
of the biblical Apocalypse in much the
same vein
scp-59999 is sealed in seven different
parts each behind its own encryption
culminating in one apocalyptic ending so
at this point you're probably thinking
what actually is
scp-59999 what could be so dangerous
that it has to stay hidden in multiple
segments while on the surface
scp-5999 is just a story it details one
of the SCP foundation's many
investigations into an anomalous object
nothing too strange about that but
there's something more to it since with
the foundation there always is and it
has something to do with the images at
the header of each section of the entity
T at the top of each part of scp-59999
is a picture of a group of candles seven
to be exact but the further down you
read one by one the candles start to go
out until you reach the end of
scp-5999 delving into the first of these
sections the scp-59999 entry describes a
corpse that seems to be cursed with
multiple anomalous properties after the
assault and murder of one miss
Jacqueline hallcroft her remains were
scattered according to this entry any
person coming into contact with a part
of Miss holcroft's deceased body or
anyone who learns about what caused her
death will experience anomalous effects
these manifest in various ways for
example subjects May hallucinate that
they see a disheveled woman with wounds
similar to miss wholecroft's before her
dismemberment this site is sometimes
accompanied by Sounds of whispering and
even begging that calls the subject
seeing and hearing things by their name
others have reported during an unknown
song set to the tune of Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star the anomalous influence of
this whole cross dismembered remains is
known to continue until a subject's
death with many reporting seeing the
woman's deceased body lurking in their
old photos or suffering sleep paralysis
as they feel something being forcibly
removed from their guts some subjects
even report discovering body parts and
organs anything from fingers to eyes to
teeth to hair and finding it at random
places such as when opening a drawer or
in their food finally a number of
subjects affected by the remains of Miss
wholecroft have reported a specific
irrational fear the fear that the chains
are weakening even after the foundation
recovered Jacqueline hallcroft's bones
and her remains were buried in a proper
funeral the effects that herb dead body
parts had over living subjects did not
stop subjects reported their children
went missing and the attendees had Miss
holcroft's funeral Were Somehow
spontaneously disemboweled after the
ceremony to keep these effects to a
minimum the foundation apparently has a
containment procedure in place the
scp-5999 entry details something called
procedure Sevenfold wherein the SCP
Foundation gathers seven civilians and
brings them to a location called
Albright Manor on October 30th these
seven people are sedated and awake on
the night of October 31st all entrances
to Albright Manor are sealed trapping
the civilians inside observe via a
network of surveillance devices
throughout the manner procedure
Sevenfold always results in the deaths
of the seven civilian Witnesses brought
in by the foundation whether they are
told to perform a ritual or offered as a
sacrifice is unclear the following
morning Foundation cleanup Crews will
remove the remains of these people
disposing of their bodies with an
incinerator for the rest of the year
until procedure Sevenfold needs to be
conducted again Foundation Personnel on
site at Albright Manor are instructed to
be careful around any surfaces that
contain the phrase this is where I died
by now you are most likely wondering
what the remains of Miss wholecroft and
procedure Sevenfold have to do with
anything we've talked about so far what
is the connection to scp-001 the
database is there something linking an
anomalous corpse with the foundation's
knowledge of its own fictional existence
what does a fear of the Chain's
weakening mean and why do none of these
questions seem to acknowledge what those
seven candles represent or why they're
still gradually going out scrolling
further through scp-59999 doesn't seem
to yield many more answers though in
fact the more of the sections you look
into the less it seems to be about Miss
holcroft or even make any link to the
database and the deeper you go the fewer
candles remain lit the next few portions
of the scp-5999 entry are dedicated to
completely different investigations that
have little to nothing to do with
procedure Sevenfold Miss holcroft corpse
and the anomalous effects it creates are
also absent in later segments of this
entry in the SCP archive so if the curse
body parts of Jacqueline holcroft are
not
scp-5999 then what is one report details
the fates of a mobile task force trapped
in a fog shrouded town here they
encounter a lamb that appears to be
Undead and evolves into an ungodly
winged Beast before the MTF team's very
eyes another that follows is a
transcript of an exorcism during a
classified Foundation operation One
agent Grace was possessed by a demonic
entity and sent to the Department of
demonology specialist in demonic
psychology Dr Peter McNeil attempted to
remove the demon inhabiting agent Grace
however after trying to intimidate the
Demonic entity with various passages
from Biblical texts it appears as though
maybe the demon was able to spread its
influence to both agent Grace and Dr
McNeil of course neither of these
reports seem to answer or any of the
pressing questions or explain the exact
nature of
scp-5999 as you go further into the
entry you can't help but notice how
often chains are referenced in fact that
seems to be the only thing constant in
all these disjointed segments mentions
of a failure of the chains to hold What
Lies Beneath and chains that have become
too few in number to hold it all create
the sense that something once was locked
up sealed securely away is managing to
break free then finally as the last
candle goes out you are literally
brought face to face with the horror of
scp-59999 and its true nature is
revealed to you a decaying desiccated
corpse stares out of the screen at you
its eyes are sunken deep into its skull
lips shriveled almost completely away
exposing rows of rotten teeth could it
be Miss holcroft's body you aren't sure
what you are sure of is The Corpse's
face is getting closer to the screen and
now it's smiling at you you can feel
your heart pounding beating against your
rib cage has the world around you begins
to fade and your life slips away from
you the last thing you see is the Grim
face of the corpse staring out at you
with its dead sunken eye
the truth of scp-5999 is that it has
been specifically designed to kill
whoever reads it by whom you may be
asking by the SCP Foundation themselves
cast your mind back to the database and
remember that the overseer Council are
aware of their own fictional existence
they know that they aren't real and plan
to use them a medical agent to take out
the SCP Wiki authors that created them
scp-5999 is that kill agent an entity
created by fiction to kill those living
in reality
scp-5999 works by drawing a person in
offering disjointed and disconnected
horror stories as a means of grabbing a
reader's attention further and further
down through the entry that person will
go searching for the meaning behind
these Chilling Tales and therein lies
the Trap each layer each section of
scp-5999 that you read is another candle
extinguished and with every flame that
goes out a seal is broken a chain
becomes Unbound allowing The Entity
contained within the archive entry
itself to get closer its sole purpose is
to fulfill the proposal laid out by the
o5 council after learning that they were
fictional along with the entire SCP
Universe by pulling you in with the
mystery and Intrigue of the confusing
convoluted stories
scp-5999 is able to deploy jumping out
of the screen towards you condemning you
to a dark and grisly fate or maybe
that's just what the o5 council and the
SCP Foundation wants us to think either
way it might just be safer to get your
SCP knowledge here at SCP explained
you're a pizza delivery person for a
company were not at Liberty to name it
may seem like a thankless job but you're
part of the thin cross between
satisfaction and starvation for people
who really don't feel like cooking or
going out tonight you're a tried and
true Pizza veteran you seen a lot on the
job from people who try to rob you on
their own doorsteps to one guy who tried
to tip you with a clearly fake Rolex but
you haven't seen anything like the
insanity you're about to encounter
tonight that's because you're about to
get sick really really sick and we know
there's probably a lot of diseases you'd
rather not catch but trust us no disease
bites quite like
scp-3760 but back to you you're parked
on the saddle of your prize bicycle
pedaling for your life the biggest order
you've ever delivered strapped to the
cargo rack behind you eight large Meat
Feast pizzas you figure you're heading
towards the most hopping or at least the
hungriest party in the city and despite
the frustration of needing to Ferry this
hot cheesy nightmare to its destination
parties have historically been pretty
good tippers little do you know your
prize customer is about to give you much
more than just a tip you pull outside
their ground level apartment and park
your bike there's no music coming from
the apartment you're heading to strange
you pick up your precious cargo and
trudge towards the door barely managing
to ring the bell with your spare Pinky
the door swings open instantly as though
the occupant was just standing behind it
the whole time waiting for you when the
door opens you're not sure what to make
of what you see inside there isn't a
party there doesn't even seem to be a
group just one person standing there and
staring at you and something about this
person is just wrong his skin seems to
be an oddly unnatural color it has a
slightly gray Hue like it's rotting and
you see that the stranger's shirt is
torn in several places you're trying
your best to remain professional and not
stare but you notice that whatever is
under these tears doesn't look like skin
it's almost like there are holes all
over his body underneath the shirt big
gaping holes and are those you're cut
off when he takes the pile of pizzas
from you and shoves what was once a
handful of dollars into your palm they
seem torn up and worst of all wet you
look past your strange customer and see
that his apartment looks just as shoddy
as he does there's stuffing torn from
the couch huge tears in the curtains
when you could swear or scratch your
bite marks on some of the wooden
furniture this man clearly needed his
pizza as you begin to step away happy to
just be rid of this freaky situation you
do something that you'll live to regret
just for a moment you lock eyes with the
customer there's something about them
that makes you feel sick they're wet and
black more like a doll's eyes than
anything that should belong to a human
just that one instant of contact is
enough to chill your bones and according
to some theories around
scp-3760 it may have been the moment of
your infection as the stranger closes
the door in your face presumably to eat
his obscene number of pizzas stumble
back to your bicycle letting your torn
up Gooey tip Blow Away In The Wind
getting out of this place is rewarding
enough but you can't chase the thoughts
of the stranger out of your mind was he
sick was he even human these are the
thoughts swimming through your head as
you cycle back to the restaurant you're
so preoccupied you don't even notice the
truck speeding towards you you get
sideswiped destroying your bike and
throwing you in the air you can feel the
snap of your arm breaking as you land
it's a horrible feeling to go along with
the horrible noise and as you fade from
Consciousness the last thought in your
mind is the black soulless eyes of the
customer when you wake up you'll find
that you're in a hospital bed with your
arm in a cast The Doctors tell you that
you're phenomenally lucky to be alive
given the severity of the crash the
doctor says that you're dealing with a
compound fracture in your right arm as
well as some nasty cuts that required
stitches but otherwise you're fine the
hospital insists that you at least stay
the night though and you oblige but that
night you find it's difficult to sleep
partially because of the pain but mostly
because of an extremely strange sound
coming from inside the cast around your
arm it's a scraping noise like something
sharp scratching at the interior you
figure it must just be some strange side
effect of the pain meds you're not going
to let worry eat you up on the inside
something else will be doing that soon
enough you're discharge from the
hospital the next day and told that you
should be fine in a couple of months as
though that's some kind of consolation
you try to carry on with your daily life
as much as you can with one arm out of
commission but that awful crunching
noise from inside your cast persists you
even start to become paranoid that some
sort of insect is trapped inside or
worse a swarm of insects but you aren't
left with that uncertainty for Long by
the next morning your cast has fallen
off will not Fallen per se a more
accurate a description would be that it
was chewed off from the inside and not
by something trapped in there with your
arm but by your arm itself when you
finally see it it doesn't even look like
an arm anymore the flesh has turned gray
that same sickly gray of the customer's
skin the night of your accident but
worse still from the top of the hand
down to the base of the forearm your
entire arm is split open into a Fang
line chattering mouth when you've gotten
over the initial horror of seeing the
mutations that have taken hold of your
arm you notice something about the teeth
in the second mouth they're nothing like
human teeth their vicious Jagged
triangles each one like a dagger these
are unmistakably shark's teeth you give
yourself the luxury of having a good
screen after all what else are you
supposed to do after you find your arm
as turned into some kind of fleshy shark
mutant you notice that you can hardly
even feel the snapping of its jaws like
it isn't even really a part of you and
as much as you try to tense and release
what used to be the tendons in your
forearm there is no change for all
intents and purposes that limb is no
longer yours it just happens to be
attached to you not only that but it's
always very very hungry as quickly
became evident from the fact it made
such short work of the cast that had
been containing it not long ago you can
see that the graying flesh is beginning
to spread from your forearm to your
bicep it's almost like little by little
your tissue is being switched somehow
you're innately aware that if you don't
feed your arm it'll get even worse
suddenly everything about the strange
customer from the night of the accident
makes sense he had whatever you have now
only worse he was just hoping that the
pizzas would keep the beast at Bay and
you very much hope the contents of your
fridge will do the same wasting no time
you grab some processed ham and raw
chicken you're not an idiot you know
that if this thing is anything like a
real shark it's only going to be
interested in meat but when you shove
the processed meat into the nibbling maw
in your forearm you notice that it seems
to spit the food out something tells you
that your offering was too dead now
you're really afraid will this thing
want life prey will that be the only way
to stop it from taking the rest of your
arm or even more the thought terrifies
you it's like being Venom except you
don't even get a new alien friend or any
cool superpowers for your trouble but
you're smart you're resourceful you
don't intend to let this thing take over
your life without a fight and you've
always believed what GI Joe taught you
knowing is half the battle sadly doing
an internet search for my injury is
somehow mutating into a shark how do I
stop this didn't do much good and you
don't want to go to a doctor because
part of you expects to be immediately
shipped off to the nearest circus or
military research lab instead you throw
on a thick leather jacket that you hope
your new shark arm will take a while to
eat through and head to the library of
the nearest to Medical College if
anywhere has sources on the most obscure
of medical problems this would be the
place and after hours of searching
through index cards you find it what
seems to be the one and only source of
this ludicrous Topic in the thousands
and thousands of books a series of
journal entries made by Dr Keith
Woodward ship's medical officer aboard
the USS Kirby Circa 1922 even the
library's indexing system prefaces the
source with a disclaimer that it's
likely 25 quackery and 75 ocean Madness
but that doesn't deter you and he poured
in a storm Dr Woodward told the
horrifying tale of the USS Kirby's
collapse due to a sudden and
unexplainable contagion it began with
the infection of a sailor on the ship
named Willis Riggs who had fallen
overboard and had his foot partially
eaten by a shark much like your arm the
man's foot slowly became the ravenous
all-devouring mouth of a shark itself
little by little it spread to the other
crew members through unknown means any
injuries sustained by the crew didn't
heal like normal but instead became this
vicious living shark tissue soon these
ever-hungry new mouths LED them to eat
each other and then themselves from the
inside out even after the humans they
once were could be considered long dead
those hungry Jaws kept snapping there
was no cure there was no solution
everyone on the boat was recorded as
having mysteriously died at Sea that is
the curse of
scp-3760 and as if On Cue you look down
to see that the shark's mouth in your
arm has chewed through the leather of
your sleeve like it's nothing it's
hungry and nothing will satiate it but
perhaps some sacrifices need to be made
if you want to stop it from getting
worse just as the thought crosses your
mind a needle full of sedative is
injected into your neck everything goes
dark very quickly and when you wake up
you're in a clean clinical white room
you are now a officially under
containment by the SCP Foundation not
that you'll know that anytime soon this
may seem like the calvary has arrived
but sadly for your sake they have no
interest in curing you they're just
eager to gather more data on how your
condition progresses
scp-3760 exists as a latent infection in
well over half of humanity but its
horrific mutating effects are activated
in only a relative few there have only
been
2785 recorded cases of scp-3760 activity
observed between 1958 and 2016. this is
thanks to the foundation's secret weapon
against the shark mutation Menace
subliminal memetic agent Kappa Omicron
or smako a widely distributed memetic
agent that suppresses the symptoms of
infection in most people not that this
would provide much comfort to you as you
join the almost 3 000 others who have
been infected and you are doomed to
slowly turn into an abomination in your
your containment chamber if it's any
consolation you may not see the truly
Advanced stages of the disease the most
common cause of death Among The
Afflicted is being eaten by their own
ravenous shark mouths long before it
changes your entire body actually come
to think of it that's not much of a
consolation at all but hey when it comes
to anomalous mutations we're sad to
report that there's rarely a happy
ending in store for those Afflicted and
scp-3760 is no exception to the rule an
SCP Foundation researcher is monitoring
the salt content of a large tank filled
with water inside the tank just under
the surface is a huge mass of rusted
metal though few pieces have a couple
specks of their original shiny surface
visible through the dark red exterior
the researcher suddenly looks up from
his task though does anyone else hear
that noise it's a terrible noise like
metal scraping and scratching against
each other but the Heap of metal in the
tank isn't moving still all the noises
continue though and the researcher keeps
staring at the unmoving hunk of metal in
the tank all he can think about is
diving in and letting his body become a
part of it keps emerged in a big
saltwater tank at the SCP Foundation is
an object but perhaps a more accurate
way to describe it would be as a machine
referred to as scp-882 the machine's
containment tank is required according
to containment procedures to be filled
with at least 40 percent pure sea water
direct from the ocean if at any point
the rusty surface of scp-882 begins to
show signs of becoming more like shiny
metal than the percentage of seawater
must be raised to 100 percent until the
metal is completely covered in Rust
trying to keep metal rusted that might
sound like a strange concept but you'll
see why it's so necessary soon
scp-882 looks like little more than a
collection of seemingly random pieces of
metal all fused together as if they had
been welded gears cables pulleys screws
and belts all different shapes and sizes
all made of different Metals all of
these various components do not appear
to be uniform or have been made to fit
each other and are instead all stuck
together in one big unstructured mass of
metal objects but scp-882 wasn't built
to be like this instead this seems to be
the result of one of
scp-882's latent anomalous properties
the absorption of metal any metal that
comes into contact with scp-882 will
become permanently attached to it and
after a few days will be a new part of
scp-882 that means that any metal that
touches that new piece will also become
a part of scp-882 and on and on because
of this strange property absolutely no
metal is allowed to be brought near
scp-882 and only organic materials are
permitted to come into Direct contact
with it that includes using non-metal
alternatives to keep the machine
securely contained
scp-882 is suspended in its salt water
tank by organic cotton fiber lines which
also require changing on a daily basis
any and all researchers that the SCP
Foundation has interacting with the
metallic Mass are required to wear thick
cotton gloves at all times you might
think that this sounds pretty easy to
contain just don't let it touch metal no
problem organic materials only no
removal rust Allowed no sweat the
foundation staff working with 882
probably felt the same way until they
started hearing
scp-882 make noise while scp-882 is
usually silent Personnel that spend an
extended period of time close to the
machine have reported intense grinding
or clicking noises coming from somewhere
in the mess of metal components while
they start out low and are almost
unnoticeable these sounds get gradually
louder until event eventually they
become completely unbearable for human
beings to withstand so then why don't
these sounds show up on audio recordings
because the grinding or clicking noises
from
scp-882-r and actually extreme auditory
hallucinations but even though they
aren't real these sounds are more than
capable of driving anyone who hears them
into a state of psychosis and here's
where things get tricky the only way to
make the noises stop is to offer scp-882
more metal as mentioned any object that
is made of any type of metal that comes
into contact with the machine becomes a
part of its mass allowing new objects to
become fused to the surface of scp-882
will cause the grinding noises to
subside but will increase
scp-882's Mass permanently if the noises
aren't stopped though then the mental
state of those afflicted by them only
grows worse and some victims of
scp-882's auditory hallucinations have
gone so so far as to throw themselves
into the tank containing it where they
were killed almost immediately their
bodies crushed to death by anomalous
forces and becoming unrecoverable from
the tangle of gears and random metal
objects the SCP Foundation now requires
any of its Personnel that work directly
with scp-882 to report any instances of
noise coming from the machine
additionally whoever reports hearing
strange sounds in the vicinity of
scp-882 must turn themselves in for a
full psychological evaluation depending
on the results the researcher will
either be free to return to their work
or will face containment themselves at
an undisclosed Foundation facility the
surface of scp-882 exhibits an extreme
resistance to damage according to the
foundation's testing the metal structure
has a tensile strength and toughness
stronger than aircraft-grade titanium
alloy despite this the machine still
seems to be constructed of weaker metals
like tin iron gold and many others still
yet to be identified it takes extreme
heat and several hours of exposure at
that to cut even the smallest portion of
metal from the main bulk of scp-882 but
where did it come from the SCP
Foundation First recovered scp-882 near
an island commonly on the northeast
coast of banks Island one of the larger
islands in the Canadian Arctic
archipelago strangely not a single scrap
of metal not even underground metallic
ore was found within a one-mile radius
of where the machine was discovered
Strangers still the small town located
nearby seemed to be abandoned with signs
that it had been devoid of any human
life for quite a number of years the
collection of fused metal components
later designated
scp-882 was found submerged in seawater
the machine was coated in Rust and the
foundation has chosen to keep it in the
same Rusty state it has been kept in
since its containment why because when
Foundation personnel first attempted to
remove
scp-882 from the water and the rust
began to flake away from scp-882's metal
surface its gears and cogs started to
turn Foundation Personnel on site were
unsure of what the machine's purpose was
but wanted to Halt it in case it proved
deadly a number of ill-fated attempts at
containment occurred soon after with any
person getting too close to scp-882
finding themselves pulled into its mass
and crushed to death between turning
cogs after multiple accidents that
resulted in the demise of foundation
Personnel Dr Charles gears authorized
the use of
scp-2519 to help stop the movement of
scp-882's Gears
scp-2519 is an audiophile titled Babylon
mp3 which features the song By the
Waters of Babylon by Philip Hayes and
texts from the biblical Psalm 137
playing this file can cause malfunctions
to occur in various electronic and
mechanical device
normally reducing the speed at which
they can operate or causing a complete
cessation of a machine's function in
scp-882's case the sound of Babylon mp3
successfully slowed The Machine's moving
Parts allowing Foundation Personnel to
safely get closer to it teams then cut
the massive metal down to a more
manageable size with extreme heat and it
was finally contained however another
question arises surely if scp-882 is a
machine then it must have a purpose
right and perhaps more importantly what
is its connection to the infamous
machine loving group of Interest the
Church of the broken God both of these
questions might just have one easy
answer to put it plain and simple
scp-882 may just be the heart of the
broken God the Church of the broken God
is a religious organization that the SCP
Foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
life specifically biological flesh-based
life is inherently wrong even evil this
group worships mechanization the process
of making something or someone more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church there were two
gods yaldaboth and McCain who created
Humanity together yaldabath was the god
of Flesh and animal Instinct granting
humans their bodies while meccane the
gotta machine and intellect bless man
with the power of free thought as
humankind developed and its civilization
began building machines yaldaboth became
enraged that they were ignoring the
instincts she had bestowed upon them she
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man in an attempt to revert them to the
animals she had intended to be as Legend
goes McCain acted as Humanity's Savior
and intervened to stop yaldabov they got
a machine shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow God fragments of
meccane rained down on plan planet Earth
fragments that the Church of the broken
God believes it is their duty to recover
however a number of these pieces are
cataloged to scps that the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
they are scp-882 or is broken heart to
the church
scp-271 his broken gift
scp-813 his Broken Eyes
scp-1139 his broken tongue
scp-635 has broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to
scp-217 often using anomalous technology
members of the Church of the broken God
intend to uncover or steal these various
components the church's ultimate goal is
to bring the correct pieces together and
completely restore McCain's form it is
their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual Enlightenment and bless
them with new mechanical forms so that
they can discard their current Flesh and
Blood bodies however the foundation and
the church are certainly not the only
groups to have a fascination with
scp-882 near the banks Island site where
the machine was first discovered
Foundation Personnel encountered a man
the sole survivor of the nearby town
this individual by the name of Richard
Wright was apprehended and brought in
for questioning with Dr gears during
their interview Richard revealed a
number of details about the townsfolk
who had first uncovered
scp-882 and what ultimately became of
them according to his account the
community formed a cult around
scp-882 after a man named Alan found it
the machine's Parts had begun to turn
and move but with no clear indication as
to what was powering it soon a local
priest Father Pat also took an interest
in scp-882 both he and Alan seemed to
share the belief that the machine had
been built by God for a higher purpose
and encouraged residents of the nearby
town to come and offer metal to it
Richard explained that the locals were
plagued by the auditory hallucination is
typical of long-term exposure to scp-882
kept awake at all hours of the Night by
clanking grinding and the screaming of
metal before long Richard noticed more
and more metal items being fed to the
machine with many local residents
content to just sit and stare at the
mass he also noticed that Father Pat and
Alan both seem to be acting strangely
around the machine insisting that all
the metal that had been added to it
still wasn't enough then one night
during a communion before
scp-882 Father Pat took a pair of pliers
and began tearing out Town's people's
metal fillings Richard watched in horror
as the priest wrenched teeth from the
mouths of ordinary people and threw them
into
scp-882 but still claiming it wasn't
enough then he turned on Ellen accusing
him of hiding metal from the great
machine inside his body the townsfolk
turned on Alan the first one to find
scp-882 and threw him and his metal hip
in to the machine his body breaking
under its moving Parts luckily scp-882
remains contained at least for now until
the members of the Church of the broken
God find a way to reunite the heart of
their god with the other pieces of its
scattered body and meccane can Rise
Again an outcome that his worshipers are
eager to bring to fruition sooner rather
than later one fine morning your distant
Aunt Carol came to your family home in
an almost frantic state of excitement
Carol had always been a bit eccentric
totally harmless of course but what you
describe as being on the more zealous
side of religious predictably she wanted
to ask you and your family to come to
church with her seeing as you don't see
Aunt Carol often you and your family
decide that there's no harm in indulging
her you're not an atheist family by any
means in fact you were all race Catholic
but it felt like it'd been forever since
you last went to church Aunt Carol
wanted to show you and your family the
special celebrations that went on at her
church you remember her practically
grabbing you by the wrist and dragging
you to the building her eyes filled with
a crazed enthusiasm that's when you saw
something incredibly strange there were
Shadows moving behind the elaborate
stained glass windows thousands of tiny
Shadows starting around and this low
humming noise you faintly recognize what
was that noise it was the Cry of cicadas
but this was only early spring what were
cicadas doing awake at this time of year
you didn't get much time to ponder this
question in the next few seconds you and
the entire church were surrounded by
heavy duty tactical Vehicles what
appeared to be a large and heavily armed
SWAT team poured out of the vehicles
unbeknownst to you these were a mobile
task force sent in by the SCP Foundation
specifically
mtfy99 also known as The Altar Boys a
specially trained group of foundation
agents used for anomalies of a religious
nature you your aunt and the rest of
your family are rounded up to be
debriefed and given amnestics one of the
last memories they took from you was the
side of foundation agents dragging
bloody bodies out of the church as the
doors opened thousands of cicadas
streamed out and disappeared into the
skies but these weren't like any kind of
cicada you'd ever seen they were
beautiful the rainbow colored Wings
reminded you of ornate's stained glass
who could have guessed that these pretty
little bugs are tied to an entity very
likely to bring about an XK Class end of
the world scenario someday in the future
the bugs the bodies in the church and
even your aunt's incredibly strange
Behavior All Fall underneath the
umbrella of a ketter class anomaly known
as
scp-3004 but to truly understand this
anomaly that was once thought to be
destroyed and the implications of it
still living today we need to go back
600 years to Ireland in the 15th century
this Sarah was believed to be the origin
of a Gaelic religious movement known as
capelanji or the singers in English a
splinter sect of druidism but this was
no fringe cult the singers were a
mainstream religion in the British Isles
for several hundred years its members
included people of all social classes
from lowly peasants to powerful and
respected figures they mingled heavily
with Christians mostly Irish Catholics
and at some point in history came close
to overtaking Christianity as the
dominant religion in Ireland so who were
these people if they're supposedly such
a large part of recent history in the
area like most Druids their relationship
with nature was a key part of their
belief system in particular they prized
an extinct species of cicada known as
sycadera luculenta or the stained glass
cicada in English the life cycle of
birth and resurrection that the cicadas
underwent fascinated the singers and
they performed a number of holy rituals
around it one recorded ritual was the
celebration of children entering
adulthood that was marked by them first
losing their baby teeth but the rituals
of the singers accidentally opened some
kind of door to a being from a different
plane of reality dubbed scp-3004-1 by
the foundation this being is an
immensely powerful thought form that the
foundation believes to be a pitis phage
or faith eater it appears to have been
attracted to our universe by the rituals
of the singers and so took a form
relevant to their beliefs namely a huge
cicada in order to feed on their faith
if things had stopped there then this
would be an almost innocent symbiotic
relationship but the interactions
between
scp-3004-1 and our world led to
dangerous consequences due to its
powerful reality warping abilities for
example during some rituals huge numbers
of stained glass cicadas would burst
from the mouths of those participating
often causing them to choke to death
other times 3004-1 would manifest us
physically in the sky above its new
worshipers causing painful boils on
whoever witnessed it and occasionally
symptoms akin to radiation sickness it
appeared that 3004-1 was growing more
powerful over time and its rise to power
was intrinsically linked to the rituals
of the singers and the existence of the
stained glass cicadas two groups that
predated the foundation the vatican's
congregation for otherworldly acts and
the English government's Royal Society
for the imprisonment of abnormality
essentially performed an all-out
religious genocide on the singers no
meaningful trace of the religion was
left when they were done aside from
their own records while they were at it
they also exterminated all the stained
glass cicadas leading to a complete stop
of all scp-3004 activity it seemed like
despite the great human and ecological
cost the anomaly had been neutralized a
few centuries later though a series of
strange cicada-related anomalous events
started to occur across across the
United States a strange man seemingly
made almost entirely from cicada kinten
would appear at christenings weddings
and funerals each time his presence
would cause the people in attendance to
do and experience horrific things and
lead to legacies of hardship and death
that would linger for decades this
became known as
scp-2852 or cousin Johnny and it should
have been the first clue that the
nightmare of
scp-3004 was resurfacing but since 3004
was already archived as neutralized
nobody made the connection sometime
later
scp-2852 incident ceased and around that
exact time
scp-3004 instances started Anew it
manifested in the form of strange
anomalous activities taking place at
Christian church services specifically
those from Roman Catholic Eastern
Catholic Anglican and Episcopalian
communities the only Clues to Outsiders
would be an in increase in reported
Church attendance and an increase in
deaths from natural causes within the
community these two stats were how the
foundation first noticed something was
amiss just as it had done with the
singers centuries before
scp-3004-1 had latched onto the beliefs
and rituals of Christians and was using
this new connection to harvest more
faith for sustenance the results were
twofold first religious fever and
excitement to attend church services saw
a huge increase secondly the actual
content of these Services took a hard
turn for the horrific much like cousin
Johnny infiltrations this really isn't
for the faint of heart by any definition
for example young people with
christ-like Stigmata wounds being bitten
to death by priests children removing
the teeth of priests before they all
start vomiting huge numbers of stained
glass cicadas there were extremely
unpleasant rituals involving castration
and even a pregnant woman giving birth
to even more swarms of stained glass
cicadas we could go on but you probably
get the idea rituals inspired by
scp-3004-1 are horrific and all seem to
involve the same extinct breed of
stained glass cicadas worshiped by the
singers before their Annihilation but
how can these insects which have been
dubbed
scp-3004-2 be here in the present if the
foundation forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago the answer is
simple but strange while they have all
the Hallmarks of being alive the stained
glass cicada is present during modern
iterations of scp-3004 events aren't
actually real genetic tests have shown
that they're actually made from a mix of
wood and real stained glass these
insects Fly Away From The Scene after
the rituals are completed traveling
around 600 miles from the site before
disappearing completely the foundation
was growing concerned about the nature
of scp-3004 especially given that
instances were becoming more frequent
and harder to contain Foundation
scientists determined that the creature
known as 3004-1 likely existed within a
layer of reality just above our own and
if it ever managed to breach our reality
the World level of violence and Chaos it
could cause would likely lead to an XK
Class end of the world scenario drastic
actions would once again be needed to
prevent this so they devised an
emergency containment procedure that
would only be used as a last resort the
procedure known as protocol dementio
advestias would use a mixture of mass
amnesic treatment and thermal objects to
completely erase Christianity from not
only the modern world but all of history
in hopes of cutting off
scp-3004-1's food supply to kill the
entity or at least prevent it from
entering our world the plan would Center
on placing a powerful Roman Catholic
reality warper who volunteered for the
job of course into an anomalous group of
machines known as the Lions by
submitting the reality warper to
lifetime of suffering and essentially
erasing him from existence so too will
it erase the world's full knowledge of
Christianity and hopefully save the
world this man will become the last
martyr dying for all of humanity he will
become the last Saint Saint Jude the
Damned bulwark against Darkness you
might ask are you sure that's necessary
there's so much we don't know about
3004-1 do we know for a fact that it's
dangerous enter agent Timothy lutterman
a member of mobile task force Sigma 25
also known as Ghostbusters Letterman was
part of a foundation project known as
sightsee Lux using an astral projection
technology that would free his
Consciousness from his body and allow it
to travel freely between metaphysical
planes in plain English they could use
Letterman's floating mind as a kind of
spy and insert it into
3004-1's Dimension they achieved this by
capturing one of 3004-1's false stained
glass cicadas and releasing it again
allowing Letterman's mind to follow at
home to its Master however what we
thought would be a simple Intel
gathering mission turned into a complete
nightmare Letterman found that 3004-1's
Dimension was entirely void aside from
the entity itself and the millions of
buzzing stained glass cicadas The Entity
was so huge and so complex that it
physically hurt to look at Letterman
observed that its form kept shifting
from a giant cicada to an old man to a
cicada nailed to a wooden cross to an
infinite mess of wood and stained glass
but even more terrifying than its
physical appearance were the contents of
its mind 3004-1 forced itself into agent
Letterman's brain and in that moment he
finally understood it the entity which
had no concept of metaphors allegory or
the Divide between fact and fiction
truly believed that it was the abrahamic
god depicted in the Bible and that all
Christians are lovingly worshiping it in
its rituals it was imposed using some of
the bloodiest parts of the Bible onto
its flock believing that's what they
wanted all the while it fed on their
faith growing bigger and more powerful
Letterman found that just being there
with the creature was hurting his soul
if it wasn't a god yet he believed it
had the power to become one in time and
he advised the foundation shouldn't send
anyone else to its Dimension it was too
great a risk to all life on Earth
perhaps to prevent the horrible fate of
all of us being destroyed by 3004-1 a
racing Christianity would be a worthy
sacrifice that is if it actually works
after all they thought destroying the
singers would neutralize 3004 once and
for all and yet here it is again for all
we know we may just be prolonging the
inevitable history is often the greatest
teacher by looking at the past we can
learn from it with the benefit of
hindsight such as in the early 20th
century when the entire planet was in
the grip of a horrifying War at the time
this conflict was often referred to as
the Great War although there was little
grade about it others knew it as the war
to end all wars the largest armed
engagements the world had known although
it would not be the last today with that
hindsight we just mentioned we know it
as World War one in June 1914 an
Archduke of Austria was shot dead by a
Serbian assassin and as a result of the
complicated treaty's forged between
various Nations soon much of the world
was involved in the war that started out
as little more than a scuffle between
neighbors the horrors of trench warfare
the Carnage caused by the earliest
chemical weapons and armored tanks left
a permanent and Lasting scar on the
world's history one still mourned and
remembered to this day the advances in
chemical and mechanized Warfare that
took place during World War One range
from the use of chemicals like tear gas
used to disable targets to more lethal
compounds like mustard gas and of course
this was the first war to introduce
tanks to the battlefield although these
were clumsy and cumbersome to begin with
it was arguably the Advent of the first
world war that forced many advancements
in armored Warfare it was the belief of
many individuals on all sides that if
the Great War was made too gruesome and
horrific to continue it would come to
its natural end this of course did not
happen only encouraging each participant
of World War One to continue advancing
their Weaponry but what if there were
weapons developed during World War one
that were too dangerous to be deployed
with every side looking for advantage
over their adversaries what if some
turned to the unethical even the
anomalous to gain the upper hand in the
war introducing
scp-186 otherwise known as to end all
wars try to imagine Weaponry that was so
incredibly Advanced for the mid-1910s
yet so horribly and unjustifiably cruel
worse than gas that can cause blisters
to form not only on the skin but also
inside the lungs more advanced than
armored vehicles with mounted machine
guns crawling across no man's land it's
hard to picture something that could be
more devastating than that especially
for the time period but a good measure
of a weapon's destructive power is
usually found in the damage it leaves in
its wake in this case
scp-186 is exactly that not the
anomalous weapons themselves but the
sight of a battle that took place
between the 24th of July and the 13th of
August in 1917. the event became known
as the Battle of hussian woods but you
won't find any mention of it in the
history books any and all records of the
battle have been secretly expunged by
the SCP Foundation and their own archive
is now the only place where someone can
find the details of what happened over
those few weeks the engagement took
place between the German Imperial Army
and forces belonging to Russia's
provisional government a small Skirmish
in comparison to the enormity of many
battles of the first world war so what
happened at the Battle if you see it in
woods to make it so horrible that it had
to be stricken from the historical
record for that we have to go back to
his Seaton a small settlement in Western
Ukraine in July of 1917 the surviving
remnants of a Russian division had been
scattered the Germans counter-attacked
against the kerninsky offensive had
driven the Russian troops to the dense
forest that surrounded the town of
isiaten you might be forgiven for
thinking that the outnumbered Russian
Force was decimated by almost 500 German
soldiers pursuing them but you would be
very very wrong as the opposing forces
met they engaged each other in a
fearsome battle but this was unlike any
encounter that had taken place over the
course of World War One or ever would
again both sides were armed with
anomalous Weaponry possessing technology
Beyond any that had ever been seen at
the time to this day the SCP Foundation
has been baffled by these weapons even
with their unique understanding of the
anomalous Foundation researchers had
been unable to replicate any of them and
instead keeps them secured in the
Munitions wing of psych-23 all under the
designation of
scp-186-1 among the recovered instances
of
scp-186-1 is a highly modified skoda M
1909 machine gun however rather than
behaving like a standard firearm this
gun would cause rapid-forming growths
not unlike tumors to appear within the
body of its targets another was
concertina wire a form of spiraled razor
wire commonly used in trenches only this
wire was coded in an unknown compound
that caused perm and hallucination
whenever the wire cut a person and
allowed the hallucinogen to enter their
bloodstream a number of rifle cartridges
were also found littered around
scp-186 sounds pretty normal for a first
World War battlefield right except these
cartridges were not filled with
gunpowder like you would expect them to
be instead they inexplicably contain
human bone ground into powder the
purpose of this ammunition or how it was
manufactured is still unknown to the SCP
Foundation as if a gun that causes
tumors and hallucination triggering wire
weren't bad enough Foundation
researchers also found a number of
grenades used by the troops at the site
of scp-186 these were British Empire
standard issue number 27 grenades but
they contained a unique anomalous gas
that was capable of passing through any
and all filters gas masks were developed
during World War One to protect soldiers
from mustard and tear gas on the
battlefield but these masks only offered
basic filtration by today's standards
even so the gas contained in these
grenades was strong enough to negate any
and all filtration systems but that was
far from its worst quality did this
unknown gas choke troops not quite did
it disable them like tear gas in a way
yes but this gas did so by making any
Soldier exposed to it experience the
sensation of having their bodies set on
fire constantly also recovered at
scp-186 were the remains of some form of
explosive and it is believed by the
foundation that it was detonated at the
culmination of the battle of Houston
Woods causing approximately a third of
the battle's total casualties Foundation
researchers estimate that almost 300
civilians were either caught in the
blast or died as a result of the
crossfire between the German and Russian
forces the soldiers involved were also
all permanently incapacitated or killed
or or at least almost all of them so
where did these anomalous weapons come
from and why were they used just in this
battle not throughout the first world
war according to records kept from the
public by the SCP Foundation the German
troops in the Houston Woods were
accompanied by a Hungarian advisor to
their military named matyas nemes under
his orders they specifically targeted
and tracked the Russian division that
was retreating from them who were
similarly accompanying a French
scientist Dr Jean tahand it was these
two men nemes and Durand who were
responsible for arming the Germans and
Russians with their arsenals of
anomalous weapons they had ensured that
their inventions of death had only
received limited manufacturing and had
intentionally joined opposing sides of
the war effort to test their Creations
in real Combat in other words it appears
that dohand and the Maze has been
working together since the beginning of
the war and the troops they were with
had been manipulated into taking part in
a big test these soldiers were just as
unlucky as the civilians caught in the
crossfire today the SCP Foundation has
established an automated security
perimeter around the site of scp-186
preventing access to anyone unless
authorized everything within the
perimeter is frequently patrolled and
observed by security Personnel why the
need for so much security at an Old
Battleground given the damage caused by
the use of so many anomalous weapons
including those that the foundation was
unable to recover the area of scp-186
has become a hot spot for unusual
happenings even long after the battle of
Houston Woods ended these anomalies
include abnormal environmental or
weather conditions for example all the
trees in the southwestern portion of the
former Battlefield died and decomposed
at an accelerated rate in 1923 while the
temperature dropped to a permanent minus
15 degrees Celsius four years later
later but yet there was never any
snowfall then there were the sounds of
gunfire in 1932 despite there being
nobody inside the scp-186 site a number
of years later a para Foundation agents
disappeared on a routine patrol of the
area and were never seen again of course
23 years after the end of the war to end
all wars the world was plunged into
chaos and found itself at War once again
during this time SCP Foundation
Personnel were instructed to evacuate
the site of scp-186 based on
intelligence from their Allied
operatives who were working undercover
inside the Third Reich as the foundation
disembarked their observation posts a
fanclow was visible coming from
scp-186 four years passed and the second
world war came to a close the foundation
returned to re-establish their
containment of scp-186 and immediately
discovered 13 corpses dressed in German
army uniforms bearing the Insignia of
the fourth Panzer Army there were a
further 27 bodies of soldiers wearing
the Garb of the Soviet 22nd Army both
sets of bodies had already begun
decaying although someone had removed
the dog tags and anything else that
could identify these dead troops it
seems that history had to some extent
repeated itself as the nazian Soviet
forces had clashed on the same
Battlefield where their German and
Russian predecessors had fought during
the Battle of Houston Woods years later
in 1959 a large sinkhole formed in the
Northeast portion of scp-186 four men
were found wandering nearby all
extremely disoriented wearing
decomposing military uniforms where they
lost survivors of the Nazi Soviet battle
no these men were in World War One
uniforms German Empire and Russian
standard issue they had survived the
battle of Houston woods and Were Somehow
Still Standing even though they should
have died during the first world war how
did these troops manage this well the
final anomalous weapon recovered at the
site of scp-186 were mortar shells but
unsurprisingly these weren't your
standard high explosive artillery much
like those grenades mentioned earlier
these mortar shells contained a unique
previously unseen gas but instead of
causing the Perpetual pain of being on
fire this gas altered the biology of
animal cells that it came into contact
with somehow it triggered a change that
prevented a body's cells from ceasing
life function keeping them continuously
operational in other words it meant that
any soldiers exposed to this gas simply
could not die that's right some of the
troops involved in the Battle of Houston
Woods are still alive to this day the
SCP Foundation immediately began
Excavating the sinkhole and discovered
23 bodies buried beneath in a mass grave
there were more of the surviving World
War One soldiers kept alive for decades
by the mortar gas some of them still had
infected wounds and Battlefield injuries
that should have killed them yet their
bodies refused to Die the soldiers were
rounded up and hauled off to site-23
where the foundation researchers began
assessing them however they were unable
to glean any useful information from the
German and Russian troops that had been
Unearthed all of the soldiers exhibited
symptoms of extensive psychological
trauma and had developed various mental
disorders while buried alive under the
battlefield they had all been driven to
Insanity perhaps as a result of their
unnaturally extended lifespans maybe
from being buried underground and unable
to die for so long or perhaps it was the
wartime atrocities they witnessed that
drove the soldiers over the brink
history is a great teacher but those
willing to forget its mistakes are often
doomed to repeat them Matthias nemes and
Dr Jean Duran created the anomalous
weapons responsible for
scp-186 and similar mines would later go
on to build the atomic bomb and
countless weapons of mass destruction
after World Wars The Suffering of
countless troops and civilians these
parts of history mean nothing if we
don't allow ourselves to learn from them
and maybe that's our curse as a species
that we are doomed to fight the war to
end all wars again and again and again
you hear their footsteps coming down the
halls or are those your own can you even
tell the difference you can tell they're
getting closer and you can feel the hate
the rage you turn shaking and finally
see them standing right in front of you
but in that moment you might as well be
looking into a mirror and who knows
perhaps you are you just don't seem to
remember having so many Reflections have
you ever heard the saying you are Your
Own Worst Enemy of course it isn't
usually meant literally but what if it
was what if you had to fight a monster
that was you all of your flaws are
reflected back at you your strengths
your weaknesses your deepest fears with
no way to escape except a battle to the
death either way you're not making it
out alive it's just a matter of which
version of you survives but this isn't a
thought experiment no according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation it's very
much a reality there is a place where
this nightmare comes to life and it's
known as
scp-1919
scp-1919 is a hotel and converted
Mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built and
it almost looks like a comfortable place
to stay if you ignore the Eastern side
of the building that has sunk partially
into the ground the inside side however
is a different story where it's clear
the ravages of time have taken their
toll the floorboards and ceilings are
rotting collapsing in on themselves and
the rooms are filled with debris it's
deadly enough to explore the hotel for
these reasons alone but this is only the
beginning of the danger for a person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person or
group to enter the structure the SCP
Foundation planned a series of research
Expeditions into the abandoned building
led by Foundation scientist Dr lemkowitz
the first expedition seemed relatively
normal at least it did at the start a 39
year old Caucasian d-class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a
camera and a communication system guided
remotely by Dr linkowitz or Dr Al and
another operative a former head of the
MTF Tau 11 youth hostiles who is
referred to in this file only as t11
when he arrived at the building D7 was
unable to get inside through the front
door or Windows after several minutes of
trial and error he was finally able to
get in through the Western entrance Dr L
picked up a strange high-pitched
Whistling noise upon d7's entrance into
the building but it quickly faded away
and was disregarded by t11 D7 discovered
a torn painting a portrait of a young
woman with red hair next to the portrait
shallow scratches could be seen in the
wall the floor and parts of the ceiling
suddenly D7 ducked into a hiding place
alarmed he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing and it didn't belong to
D7 Dr L recommended that D7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity
inside but t11 overruled ordering him to
disregard that instruction and continue
his investigation D7 was told to stay at
a safe distance from whatever was inside
with him an attempt to capture it on
video d E7 turned off his flashlight in
order to better hide but t11 commanded
that he turn it back on whatever was
caught in the beam of light was
difficult for the camera to see but it
threw D7 into a panic and he began to
run in the opposite direction when
prompted to explain what he saw D7
simply said it was me D7 ran through the
dark panting with fear and exertion
unable to see where his feet were
Landing he tripped over something and
came crashing onto the ground dropping
the video camera this allowed the
observing officers to finally see what
D7 was so frightened by and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified a man
identical looking to D7 approached from
the end of the hallway making its way
towards the real D7 it was followed by
another man who also resembled D7 and
another all running toward the original
they all looked exactly like him with a
few notable differences they were
dressed in the same uniform with the
same build and the same features but
each had something slightly off about
him one was missing eyelids another had
malformed hands and the third had its
lips fused together into a fleshy Mass
beneath its nose Dr L moved to cut the
camera feed but t11 demanded that it be
kept running D7 couldn't be seen by the
camera but the microphone picked up the
sounds of Flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained Panic screams as the
duplicates set upon after a moment the
screaming stopped two hours later the
camera was broken and the Expedition
brought to a troubling end this was the
foundation's first Glimpse at the
creatures inside of scp-1919 and it was
not pretty it did however allow them to
begin understanding the nature of the
building and what happens when a person
goes inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel several humanoid
creatures manifest throughout the
building these creatures look like this
subject and are equipped with the same
clothing or items that the subject
brought inside with them though they are
nearly mirror images of the subject they
are always slightly warped in a variety
of ways these have included changes to
Limb and digit length joint Mobility
sealed nostrils lengthen Jaws hanging
loose and Limp missing eyelids and lips
that are fused together these creatures
are highly aggressive towards the
structure of the building itself as well
as to the subject that they resemble
they do not however attack each other
they appear to operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant colony once they have been
spawned by the entrance of a new person
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed
after the unfortunate end to the
Expedition the foundation prepped for a
second trip inside this time three men
were sent in with Dr L's guidance known
as D3 D4 and D9 video cameras were sewn
into their clothes to leave their hands
free and help avoid some of the issues
that came up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of D7 and further examine the hotel's
interior upon opening the door to the
building they were immediately attacked
by one of d7's copies which D9 was able
to quickly dispatch by firing his weapon
at its head next after a great deal of
reluctance the three men entered the
building where they spotted something
unusual inside Dr Al was horrified when
the camera feed revealed 17 discarded
video cameras spread across the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however because two
doubles one mirroring D7 and another
mirroring D9 emerge from the wall and
began to attack Dr Al ordered the team
to take shelter then called the team of
guards outside of the hotel's perimeter
they were ordered to begin an immediate
full perimeter lockdown preventing the
doubles from leaving the hotel D3 D4 and
D9 attempted to make their way to a safe
corner of the building but found
themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn at this point Dr Al began
to hear an unusual sound over the
microphone feed a high-pitched wine like
that of a dentist drill the operatives
on the ground couldn't hear a thing but
on Dr L's end it was deafening as the
team proceeded deeper into the hotel
they became overcome with a strange
feeling of foreboding Dr Al ordered them
to turn on their flashlights but they
refused and begged Dr L to keep quiet
when prompted to explain D9 said she can
hear you the operatives stop responding
but their camera feeds caught a faint
glowing white light coming from beneath
the door the door opened and the light
flooded the camera making the images it
captured hard to decipher just a few
frames of a quick moving female
silhouette were captured before the
cameras cut to static the bodies of D3
D4 and D9 were never recovered nor were
their cameras a third expedition was
also sent into
scp-1919 but very little is known about
what occurred during it the video
transcript is highly classified and only
those present for its events or prove to
research
scp-1919 have access to it an update to
the scp-1919 file following Expedition 3
though indicates that new information
was revealed about the hotel during the
Excursion according to the file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing
all of the other creatures the doubles
to appear the only information available
about this being is the use of the word
her in the official Foundation log about
scp-1919 this seems to match up with the
last moments of the operatives in
Expedition 2. when they told Dr L that
she can hear you and the few frames of a
female figure that were captured by
their cameras nothing else is known that
has been made available to anyone
outside of very select few only the
original report exists and all other
copies of it have been destroyed the
foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel Escape whether they are the evil
twins spawned by humans entering the
building or the mysterious female being
at the center of the entire disturbing
phenomenon the foundation is classified
scp-1919 as Euclid and a two kilometer
radius must be maintained around
scp-1919 with all roads leading to the
building are blocked or diverted so that
no vehicles are able to reach it this
perimeter is guarded by a set of at
least 40 armed and armored guards at any
given time as it has been determined
that the doubles spawn by 1919 are
equipped with whatever the human they
are copying has no one is allowed to
enter the hotel with body armor or
weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official Expedition team will
be immediately terminated no new
Expedition teams are allowed to enter
the building unless all doubles from the
previous Expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated enough time must
elapse between Expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the doubles do need to eat to survive
and will die when left alone for long
enough
scp-1919 has been sealed off from the
rest of the world so that no hapless
civilians can wander inside and find
themselves Torn to Pieces by warped
images of of themselves but that Comfort
turns cold when you realize that the SCP
Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn is it
scientific Supernatural or something
else no one can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of all of this an unknown female
presence capable of wrecking frightening
amounts of Violence by turning victims
own images against them what is the
purpose of these fun house mirror
nightmares who is she what is she and
what does she want currently the doubles
have shown no interest in leaving the
hotel except to attack Intruders and
thanks to that fact as well as the
reinforced perimeter outside these
copycats have not appeared outside of
the building itself but what happens if
they do Escape or if the entity that
controls them decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move Beyond its current containment are
you prepared to fight a vision of self
Twisted almost beyond recognition
lunging after you with wide bulbous eyes
unnaturally long arms and a distended
jaw hanging down below its neck better
hope you never have to find out it was
late October of 1993 and John Matthews
of Myrtle Beach South Carolina had just
scored a date with Sarah one of the most
popular girls in school and he had
planned the perfect night out for the
two of them a haunted house had just
been set up in town and he like many
guys before him figured he could use
that as a chance to impress his date
he'd already been through the attraction
so he knew exactly when to put his arm
around Sarah when one of the costume
actors or animatronics tried to spook
them if any of them got too close for
comfort he might even punch them just to
show Sarah How brave he was that would
be a Surefire way to impress any girl
however Jon had no idea of the real
horror that waited for him and his day
through the door doors of this seemingly
normal fun house at first the haunted
house went as normal Jon laughed at all
the fake cobwebs and plastic skeletons
making sure Sarah knew how dumb he
thought they looked he shoved away
actors dressed as ax murderers and told
them to stay away from his date it was
dark so they couldn't really see each
other's faces but Jon guessed that Sarah
was probably really impressed all in all
the date was going well until they got
to a room that Jon hadn't seen the first
time he'd been through it seemed like it
had been added overnight but at the same
time it didn't mesh with the theme the
theme of the haunted house this year was
cannibal hotel but this room looked more
like Dracula's castle complete with
actors dressed as Frankenstein The Wolf
Man and Dracula himself one of them was
even a dead ringer for the actor Vincent
Price John and Sarah watched confused as
the actors performed their routines
which just like their surroundings
seemed out of place it was total
hackneyed full of lame puns and very
basic scares though the special effects
were undeniably impressive when Jon and
Sarah walked through the room the actor
dressed as Dracula stood in front of Jon
and started pretending to hypnotize him
up close he did look a lot like Bella
Lugosi the actor who'd portrayed the
count during his first big screen
appearance this definitely threw John
off a little but unfortunately this
Dracula didn't have lugosi's acting
talents you are under my control Dracula
said waving his fingers at John and
staring at him Jon getting really sick
of this pushed the guy out of the way to
move on to the next room but when he did
he felt that something was really really
wrong here he practically dragged Sarah
away from watching The Wolfman transform
and ran the rest of the way through the
house all of his bravado now gone Sarah
asked her date what was wrong and he
didn't tell her how could he without
sounding crazy when he had touched that
actor playing Dracula something hadn't
felt right even through his student Cape
John had been able to tell that
something was wrong he was cold and
rigid not like a human being but like a
robot or a wax dummy this is just one of
multiple complaints from Halloween
attractions around the United States
that prompted the action of the SCP
Foundation several witnesses described
either seeing people that resembled
classic movie Monsters or living lacks
models of those monsters appearing in
various haunted houses corn mazes
carnivals and strip malls across the
country the foundation has designated
this troop of hammy wax actors
scp-4153 during performances
scp-4153 used wax to alter their
appearance produce props including fake
blood and gore and even manipulate wax
objects from afar while this results in
some uncanny special effects the content
of the performances tend to be pretty
standard classic haunted house Fair they
mostly do things like reenacting scenes
from classic horror films and telling
spooky jokes with a little fake blood
here and there when the foundation
arrived at the Myrtle Beach attraction
they apprehended the various wax
characters and determined that their
Eerie resemblance to the classic horror
characters wasn't just makeup after the
horror some of these Foundation
employees had seen on the job living
lacks models of Frankenstein's monster
and Dracula seemed almost cute in
comparison and the troop of wax actors
were taken to site 9 for questioning and
containment the first member of the
troop to be interviewed on site was
Dracula dubbed
scp-4153-017 by the foundation he was
interviewed by agent Timothy West who
was totally unimpressed with Dracula's
shtick he tried to hypnotize agent West
an act which he flatly refused to
indulge in Dracula provided the agent
with seemingly no useful information
only responding to questions with
cliches like we were all dead the whole
time and the log was coming from inside
the house the next wax figure to be
interrogated was Frankenstein's monster
AKA
scp-4153-015 who was interviewed by
agent Samantha henwick much like how
scp-4153-017 stayed fully in
characterist Dracula during his
interview
scp-4153-015 seemed to really believe
that he was actor Boris Karloff who
played Frankenstein's monster in the
1930s
the SCP spoke in an exact imitation of
karloff's voice and speech patterns and
talked to agent henwick as if she was
another actor on a movie set he talked
about how honored he was to be part of
the project and asked are we rolling
when he noticed the conversation was
being recorded agent Henrik responded to
the scp's comments with confusion a fact
which he took to mean that she was
staying in character like a true actor
he took a moment to prepare himself
before pulling his own head off much to
the horror of agent henwick the last and
probably most interesting of the
interviews conducted in 1993 was with
the wax figure who resembled Vincent
Price more specifically Vincent Price
and his role as Henry Jared in 1953's
House of Wax a movie about a mad
sculptor who made wax figures out of the
corpses of his victims this wax figure
was designated as CP
4153-036 and was interviewed by agent
Gerald Penn started the interview with a
simple question why do you try to
frighten people
scp-4153-036 had an equally simple
answer why does anyone try to frighten
it's fun to be frightened almost as much
fun as it is to do the frightening
Penn was skeptical pointing out that the
wax figures act wasn't especially
frightening the SCP laughed dismissively
telling pen to have some respect for the
classics Penn was still not having any
of it he had been with the SCP
Foundation for 20 years at this point
and he'd seen enough Real Horror that
the so-called Classics had no effect on
him whatsoever he pressured price for
answers but instead of responding with a
straight answer price launched into a
speech about his feelings on monsters
he said you'll call any o for the steak
knife hunting gaggles of teens a monster
these days there's no wit no humor no
charm where's the passion the
artisanship where's the sense of theater
would you like to know something
peculiar I've almost never played a
monster or I've played villains most
certainly but not monsters only men
besieged by Fate driven to Revenge still
I've always had a fondness for them even
as a child I sympathize more with the
monster than the hero
agent Penn who at this point was really
getting tired of all the theatrics
started to interject but when he opened
his mouth to speak he was only able to
get a few words out before his tongue
went numb and rigid in his mouth he
could no longer move it agent Penn tried
to speak but his tongue was too solid
and heavy to do anything more than knock
uselessly against his bottom teeth he
felt something dislodged inside his
mouth and he hoped maybe it was the
feeling of his tongue being freed from
whatever spell the SCP had put it under
but then he started to feel a tearing
and a sticky heaviness in his bottom jaw
agent pen reached up and felt around
inside his mouth he started to scream
indistinctly when he realized to his
horror that his tongue had ripped off he
pulled it out of his mouth and when he
held it in his hand his fears were
confirmed somehow it had become nothing
more than a lump of pink wax now
completely tongueless agent Penn
continued to babble frantically No Doubt
find a curse at the wax creatures
sitting in front of him
scp-4153-036 finally paid attention to
his interviewer's distress at this point
he turned to agent Penn with a look of
disapproval and disappointment and said
ah dear your tongue seems to have gotten
away from you there yeah allow me the
SCP leaned towards agent pen and though
the agent wanted to resist he found that
he could no longer move his arms in fact
his whole body had gone numb and rigid
just like the wax tongue the only
movement he was capable of was opening
his mouth and the wax for simile of
Vincent Price started molding his tongue
back to the proper shape and reattached
it inside agent Penn's mouth agent pen
whimper unable to do anything while the
scp's hands were in his mouth the
creature said hash now I warned you
about this I told you that you mustn't
disturb the wax before it hardens that
is a crucial part of the process it
needs to solidify otherwise uristic
serving the performance by the time his
tongue was reattached and reseal agent
Penn was on the verge of tears he
gurgled gasping for air wiggling his
tongue around in his mouth to make sure
that it worked the SCP returned to his
seat pleased with his own handiwork
Splendid Splendid with a snow now let's
take it from the top shall we agent pen
took a deep breath studying himself as
scp-4153-036 whispered the word action
Penn resumed the interview with the same
simple question why do you try to
frighten people
scp-4153-036 gave the same simple answer
why does anyone try to frighten him it's
fun to be frightened almost as much fun
as it is to do the frightening the
interview continued for only a few
minutes longer with both parties
repeating only things they'd said
earlier in the recording the log ends
with
scp-4153-036 once again saying have some
respect for the Classics not long after
the interview concluded Foundation
management completely lost contact with
site 9. a mobile task force was sent in
to investigate the cause of this loss of
contact and on arrival they found a
catastrophic Containment Breach not a
single member of on-site Personnel was
found alive and strangely all of their
bodies seemed to be coated in wax
further examination revealed that this
initial observation wasn't the case at
all they were just coated in Blacks no
every member of the site 9 team had all
of their major organs including their
skin surgically extracted and replaced
with sculpted wax of course this was
assumed to be the doing of scp-4153 but
oddly all of the autopsies suggested
that the removal of organs had happened
weeks before the apprehension of
scp-4153 even though all of the on-site
Personnel had seemed alive and well
right up until the Containment Breach
outside of being replaced by Wax no damn
was done to the bodies it seemed that
everyone had just dropped dead at the
same time there was one body that was
different though that of agent Gerald
Penn agent Penn's decapitated body was
found in the same containment cell that
had been used for
scp-4153-036 next to the body was a
photograph showing
scp-4153-036 holding up agent Penn's
screaming head and on the back a single
sentence was written from one horror
Aficionado to another always stay ahead
all the scp-4153 instances remain
unaccounted for and MTF Iota 10 also
known as the damn feds continue to
monitor for new sightings and reports of
activity that may be linked to the wax
troop hopefully one day they'll be taken
into Foundation custody and contain and
maybe all it will take is for them to
meet someone with a sufficient
appreciation for the classics
the SCP Foundation is an organization
that polices the abnormal in all its
forms whether it's a multi-dimensional
chaos God a big scaly monster or a very
effective coffee machine the foundation
takes a pointed interest in pretty much
anything outside the norm so you're
probably wondering what would they want
with Mr Smith a man who is about as
normal and average as could be Mr Smith
was a 47 year old African-American
construction worker with a wife and
daughter he lived a modest but contented
life he had a close circle of friends a
happy family and was well liked among
his co-workers but Mr Smith had no idea
about the anomalous nightmare barreling
down the tracks towards him Mr Smith
wasn't just about to have his life
destroyed by an anomaly he was about to
become one it seemed like a normal day
at work on the construction site when he
received a phone call it was the police
informing him that his wife and young
daughter had been involved in a terrible
car accident while this is anyone's
worst nightmare it was only the start of
the horrifying things that were about to
happen to poor poor Mr Smith that night
when Mr Smith went to sleep he fell
victim to a strange phenomenon he
started to disappear while it would be
easy to write off as the result of
mental illness like a kind of
stressed-induced mental breakdown Mr
Smith wasn't the only one who noticed or
rather didn't notice his co-workers
would slowly begin to forget details
about him even obvious things that you
could glean from simply looking at a
person like clothes height or skin color
it seemed that little by little ever
since his family died Mr Smith was
becoming an unperson this led to
increasing levels of fear paranoia and
distress as people whom he'd thought of
as his closest friends could barely
recognize him anymore thankfully Mr
Smith wasn't just going to slip into
non-existence without a fight he
realized early on that his new
conditions seemed to abide by certain
rules the effects got worse in the night
when he was alone but seemed to lessen
somewhat during the day when he was
interacting with people it seemed that
he disappeared just that little bit more
whenever he wasn't being interacted with
and perhaps he hadn't developed this
condition upon the death of his wife and
child maybe he'd had it for a while but
it was the constant presence of his
family that kept the effects from
worsening but now that he'd properly
identified the problem Mr Smith could
begin devising some solutions if nobody
else was there to interact with him at
night he'd keep his position in reality
stable by interacting with himself Mr
Smith would repeat his own name to
himself regularly reaffirming his
existence to himself he'd often check
his own pulse to feel the rhythm of his
heartbeat he'd write detailed
descriptions of himself either on his
own body or a surrounding surface and in
one particular stroke of Genius he
devised a method of recording his own
voice talking to himself and playing it
back while he was asleep to Stave off
reality Decay during the day while at
work or just existing socially in the
world you do everything he could to
constantly interact with people that way
they could keep reaffirming his presence
and therefore continuing his existence
the symptoms of Mr Smith's condition are
somewhat similar to a rare mental
illness known as the kotard delusion in
which a patient believes they are dead
dying or don't even exist except in Mr
Smith's unfortunate case the delusion
was becoming a reality and this was a
reality that Mr Smith could only hold
off for so long little by little the
coping mechanisms he'd built to manage
his new life began to collapse people in
his inner circle truly began to forget
him his company no longer recognized him
as an employee to the people who barely
knew him he little more than a ghost a
kind of palpable absence this was the
point when the SCP Foundation finally
got involved they swooped in and
apprehended Mr Smith redesignating him
as
scp-1467 it was one of the rare
occasions that the foundation didn't
need to apply any amnestic treatment to
bystanders because due to the nature of
Mr Smith's anomalous activity almost
everyone who knew him was already in the
process of forgetting him with a
foundation interviewed a man that Mr
Smith referred to as a close friend he
couldn't even recall Mr Smith's basic
physical traits with any reliability
because of Mr Smith's condition the
foundation had real difficulty verifying
elements of his backstory Mr Smith told
the foundation researchers everything
about himself about his family and his
life before but field agents were
stumped whenever they tried to follow up
on the information first there were
issues with the existence and fate of
his supposed wife and child no records
were ever found of either of these
people existing and there was no
existing documentation to prove that Mr
Smith was ever married the foundation
also looked into the deaths of Mrs Smith
and her child there were no records of a
car crash in the area that Mr Smith
directed them to but that's not all
there were also no death records nor any
Graves ever found the construction
company that Mr Smith claimed to work
for had no records of his employment
they couldn't find any of Mr Smith's
supposed extended family either the only
proof that he had ever existed was his
physical body locked in a foundation
humanoid containment cell and Mr Smith's
own words if you think this sounds like
a living nightmare then Mr Smith would
wholeheartedly agree with you the
effects of his anomalous nature
traumatized Mr Smith he was diagnosed by
Foundation therapists as suffering from
bipolar depression as well as chronic
sleep deprivation though if you
disappeared a little more every time you
slept you'd probably lose a lot of sleep
too the unpredictable nature of Mr
Smith's anomalous traits could have
equally unpredictable effects on the
nature of his containment so he was
classified as Euclid Mr Smith is one of
the few anomalies that is referred to by
his real name at least to his face when
referred to as
scp-1467 Mr Smith enters a state of rage
and panic and this mistake has caused
several injuries for foundation
Personnel during attempts to restrain
him after using his SCP number around
him Mr Smith is contained in a foam
padded cell to prevent self-destructive
Behavior along with three audio
recording devices though these were
installed at his own request in order to
continue his habit of recording his own
voice to play back to himself while
asleep this served the dual purpose of
not only mitigating his fading from
reality but also keeping him calm and
docile during containment and these
devices are kept in good working order
in order to avoid creating hostility
between Mr Smith and foundation's staff
while it may seem that the anomalous
effects of Mr Smith purely serve to
create a personal hell for him and him
alone the foundation wasn't so sure the
fact no records could be found of his
wife daughter or extended family was
concerning it raised one frightening
question are the effects of Mr Smith's
condition contagious if so he could be
putting a lot of people in grave danger
Foundation scientists headed by senior
researcher Dr Thorne devised a series of
experiments to better understand Mr
Smith's mysterious condition there were
22 experiments in total but things began
to get interesting at a round experiment
16. for this experiment Mr Smith was
forcibly restrained and brought into a
research chamber with research
assistants Rainier and diadir they were
told to Simply observe Mr Smith without
interacting with him and record what
happened in the process while Dr Thorne
supervised at 10 minutes and 12 seconds
the researchers were unable to recognize
the subject as Mr Smith at 14 minutes
and 32 seconds they were unable to
recognize the clothes of Mr Smith less
than 10 minutes later they were unable
to identify his Reigns five minutes
after that they couldn't identify what
Mr Smith was currently doing 10 minutes
later they couldn't even identify how Mr
Smith was sitting at almost 40 minutes
the research assistants weren't able to
identify anything of Mr Smith save for
the fact that there was some kind of
humanoid creature in the room at this
point research assistant theater started
a recording instructing Mr Smith to
describe himself on record as this
happened Smith returned to a describable
State curled up in a fetal position on
the floor there was no sign of the
restraints or the chair in which Smith
had been placed subsequent tests showed
similar results with my Center
variations in timing just by being in
physical contact with Mr Smith the chair
and the restraints had literally faded
out of existence evidence was really
pointing towards Mr Smith's anomalous
effects being potentially detrimental to
the people and objects around him but
the experiments continued they had to
know more before there was nothing left
to know the next series of experiments
were performed with d-classes and led Dr
Thorne and his team of researchers to a
number of frightening conclusions two
d-classes locked in with Mr Smith as he
slipped out of existence began
experiencing extreme states of Terror
and distress even when they could no
longer see him they could still feel the
presence of an entity in the room when
the 2D classes tried to escape one of
them was almost mistaken from Mr Smith
himself he too was now starting to slip
out of existence both d-classes were
summarily terminated and Dr Thorne began
to wonder whether Mr Smith's condition
was contagious or if he was instead
somehow able to lash out at others in
his vicinity in a more localized fashion
only two other experiments were ever
performed on Mr Smith before further
experimentation into his case was
permanently suspended in the first a
non-violent d-class was placed in Mr
Smith's cell and ordered to ignore him
Mr Smith didn't take this well he began
attacking the d-class who fought back
breaking Mr Smith's nose ironically this
physical attack was actually beneficial
to Mr Smith as the violence helped
ground him in reality and secured his
existence just that little bit more in
the final experiment Mr Smith was given
a cellmate a female d-class who was
allowed to acknowledge Him the two
appeared to become close and their time
helped Stave off Mr Smith's fading just
a little bit longer it's unknown if she
contracted his fading condition or
somehow was able to escape but one day
while Mr Smith slept she simply
disappeared Mr Smith fell into a state
of almost catatonic silence soon after
he began to speak again only to repeat I
don't want to go again and again and
again the experiments concluded for good
not long after because of his delicate
mental state Mr Smith is allowed a visit
from a therapist every week and before
any future experiments are performed on
Mr Smith researchers are required to
seek permission from his active
therapist because of his effects on the
minds of people aware of him Foundation
protocol is to terminate Mr Smith
immediately if he ever breaches
containment the site director has also
appended a memo to Smith's file
instructing Personnel to refer to Mr
Smith as
scp-1467 whenever he's out of earshot
doing otherwise will incur severe
punishments records on Mr Smith are
backed up in six separate copies and
stored in different locations in hopes
that this will prevent the information
from decaying like Mr Smith's existence
Mr Smith's stories one of pain tragedy
and existential horror there's no
shortage of scps that can cause XK Class
end of the world scenarios but sometimes
the terror of these anomalies pales in
comparison to scps that can bring one
person's World crashing down around them
according to all the SCP Foundation
studies it's likely that Mr Smith will
disappear sometime soon regardless of
their intervention sometimes the SCP
Foundation needs to get creative with
how they go about securing containing
and protecting sadly not everything can
be solved with the mobile task force or
by locking it away securely in a
concrete chamber which brings us to
scp-2480 otherwise known by the nickname
an unfinished ritual when initially
looking through the file on scp-2480 the
reader will immediately notice a number
of discrepancies throughout parts of the
entry have been crossed out they've been
struck through so they are still
readable not redacted completely for the
purposes of secrecy like many of the
details in other SCP files first and
foremost s
cp2480 has been reclassified multiple
times first as safe then change to the
infamous ketter class but now it is
listed as far more ominous presumed
neutralized it's disconcerting because
presumed definitely leaves a lot of
questions so what exactly is
scp-2480
scp-2480 is an area of dimensional
abnormality apparently created when an
occult ritual was interrupted in
November of 1952 hence the nickname of
An Unfinished ritual the source of this
anomaly is located in a heavily forested
town somewhere near the coast of
Massachusetts of course this state has
long been synonymous with many occult
happenings Massachusetts famously being
home to a number of supposedly haunted
houses and sites of Supernatural
activity and scp-2480 is no exception
seeming to fit both of those criteria in
order to keep an eye on SCP 20 2480 the
foundation has dispatched mobile task
force Epsilon 6 also codenamed the
village idiots these operatives are
working undercover in the surrounding
area and nearby Town keeping watch for
any sightings of anomalous activity
meanwhile another team MTF cyanide the
abyss gazers are stationed nearby in
case any incident should arise these
operatives have been authorized by the
SCP Foundation to employ the use of
lethal force on any and all anomalous
manifestations they should encounter
their directive is to destroy without
prejudice that sure sounds like a lot of
effort to secure something classed as
presumed neutralized the anomaly itself
is centered around an old Massachusetts
house known as bodfell Manor The Manor
was once the home of a millionaire
industrialist by the name of Cornelius P
bodfell III who died in 1952 at the age
of 86. and yes he died in the same year
that the ritual that created SCP 2480
took place but we're sure that's
probably just a coincidence right
interestingly during his life Cornelius
bodfeld apparently had something of a
fascination with the occult it was
likely disinterest that Drew him to
creating a supernatural cult known as
adidium's way little is known about this
organization and adidium's wake are not
part of the SCP foundation's groups of
Interest the list of other anomalous
groups that often rival the foundation
much like the anomaly itself they're
presumed neutralized the foundation
conducted a full-scale investigation
into bodfield Manor and were able to
unearth more information about the
aforementioned cult fortunately
Cornelius bodfeld kept a series of
meticulous and detailed journals as well
as photographs that give plenty of
insight into the activities of adidium's
wake unfortunately a lot of what they
got up to wasn't all that pleasant but
what did you expect from a group of
cultists adidium's wake would engage in
all kinds of depraved Behavior some
that's better left to the imagination
what we can say is they'd often perform
ritualistic human sacrifice and indulge
in cannibalism and these are some of
their less unpleasant crimes on-site
Personnel also uncovered sermon notes in
bodfield's journals detailing the cult
services and occult practices they also
found lists of the adidium's Wake
members including local wealthy families
and respected politicians other
industrialists like Cornelius bodfell
and even priests and other religious
figures the foundation had previously
been aware of adidium's wake but
initially dismissed the group as little
more than a decadent upper class Social
Club not worthy of a full investigation
let's review shall we we have a
dimensional anomaly in a Massachusetts
manner a cult obsessed with the
Supernatural and some sort of ritual
that occurred in November 1952 but was
interrupted before its completion all
parts of the same bizarre and twisted
puzzle but there's still a piece yet to
be uncovered that missing piece the
global occult Coalition who would have
expected the GOC to rear their ugly
heads around here though it's worth
mentioning that many of the gocs member
groups are a cult in nature so it
probably shouldn't come much as a
surprise that they were somehow involved
in this case too it goes without saying
that the SCP Foundation shares a
complicated relationship with this
particular group of interest each often
disagreeing with the other's methods
occasionally the GOC and the SCP
Foundation will put aside their
differences and act as allies against
large-scale threats like the Scarlet
King but any alliance between them is
often uneasy and short-lived in the case
of scp-2480 the foundation were first
alerted to the anomaly's existence when
they decoded a GOC distress signal
tracing its source to bodfeld manner
when the investigative team arrived they
found deceased bodies littered
throughout the estate 36 corpses in
total each of these were confirmed to be
Coalition operatives and the rest would
theorized to be dead members of
adidium's wake almost all the corpses
found at bodfill Manor displayed signs
of anomalous causes of death some had
imploded some disintegrated and others
had their bodies Twisted into fatal new
shapes at first glance and given the
goc's mission to destroy the
supernatural it looked as if they had
stormed in and interrupted the adidium's
Wake cult while they were right in the
middle of performing a ritual things
went awry
scp-2480 was created and caused everyone
nearby to die horrifically surely that's
the whole story right well not quite as
it turns out while there were no
surviving GOC operatives for the
foundation to interrogate the
investigative team were unable to
uncover documents related to the
operation in a nearby safe house used by
the GOC much of the official
documentation was destroyed in an
attempted cover-up but a torn remainder
of a mission report was recovered in the
safe House's fireplace was actually the
global occult Coalition who had
initiated the ritual though its true
purpose was lost the foundation had
learned that the scp-2480 area had been
inadvertently created by the GOC and
their heavy-handed approach to their
mission but why would an anti-occult
organization attempt a supernatural
ritual theories as to their intention
seemed to point to the penultimate piece
of the puzzle sarcasism a widespread
religious cult that worships flesh and
disease the very existence of this
religion is viewed as a threat of
apocalyptic proportions by the SCP
Foundation sarcasism was initially
founded by the grand karcissist ion but
it has since split into a number of
smaller subgroups over the Millennia and
among those groups adidium's wake the
GOC mission report fragment gathered by
the foundation describes the operative's
target to be grand karcissist ion
himself he apparently cannot be directly
perceived so few actual descriptions of
his form exist it has been no noted by
some to be humanoid in appearance at
least wearing what looks to be vestments
similar to a priests and carrying a
staff ion is able to disappear and
reappear at will and possesses a
plethora of reality altering
capabilities the sarkic founder is able
to shift and reshape any organic
material as well as having the ability
to bend the very fabric of reality
around him while he may hold the
humanoid shape this entity is certainly
not human at least not any longer
functionally Immortal Grand karcissist
ion is noted to frequently exhibit signs
of malignant narcissism and megalomania
so now the story shifts the GOC was
attempting to use the didium's Wake to
summon ion in order for them to
eradicate the leader of the sarkic
religion the plan backfired though
scp-2480 was summoned and both the cult
and Coalition operatives were killed end
of story right except there is one more
twist in this tale of Colts and Secret
and that twist came from the last place
anyone would expect it came from inside
the SCP Foundation after scp-2480 was
created by the ritual at bodfell Manor
site-13 was established in order to keep
the anomalous area contained you see if
the ritual was an atomic blast then
scp-2480 was both the crater and the
nuclear fallout from that blast except
instead of causing radiation sickness
the entire area around bodfield Manor
became dimensionally unstable and prone
to anomalous occurrences overseeing
site-13 was director Simon Oswalt a
foundation bureaucrat Simon had been
selected for this Duty thanks to his
distinct lack of imagination and because
the anomalous area of scp-2480 was
thought to be inconsequential at the
time in 1988 Oswald failed to deliver
his regular report on scp-2480's
activity this was initially thought to
be a simple error except the foundation
couldn't get in contact attacked with
site 13 why because the unfinished
ritual hadn't actually failed it wasn't
unfinished the GOC had succeeded in
summoning Grand karcissist ion and Simon
Oswald had been the one to discover this
the founder of sarcasism appeared to
Oswald he was converted and turned
against his superiors at the SCP
Foundation ion was able to exert his
influence over the former bureaucrat
swaying him to change sides by showing
Oswald to description in the
foundation's Personnel dossier on him
that referred to him as a mirthless
Dullard turning his back on the
foundation and pledging himself to
sarcasism Simon Oswalt was granted
anomalous abilities by Grand karcissist
ion Oswalt was given the power to
control an army of anomalous entities
called sarkites that he could summon
through the area of
scp-2480 grand karcissist ion dubs Simon
with a new name karcist carvas and made
him the leader of his new Army their
goal was to bring a about the sarkic
religion's ideal the dawn of a new age
of Flesh that would Spell destruction
for Humanity when the foundation lost
contact with site 13 they dispatched two
agents to investigate Samuel Rowe and
Sarah Valentine unaware of Oswald's
conversion to sarkicism and his new
purpose as karcissist carvas both agents
were captured by the sarkite creatures
within scp-2480 the same monsters were
also terrorizing the nearby Town
replacing citizens and sometimes even
kidnapping and devouring them another
team was later sent in to survey the
area only to be killed or replaced as
well with only one Survivor Dr Kalisto
Narvaez Narvaez reported on the
situation to the o5 council and in
collaboration with the global occult
Coalition the foundation launched an
assault against Oswald The Joint Task
Force of the two organizations were able
to neutralize the sarkites reclaiming
the area of scp-2480 and capturing Simon
Oswalt without his control the creatures
became directionless unable to so much
as eat or defend themselves Grand car
assist ions plan had been thwarted and
Oswalt was taken back to an SCP
Foundation site though now under a new
name
scp-2480-1 however during an operation
at containment Area 14 Oswald seemed to
suffer no effects from anesthetic or
surgical incision Foundation researchers
were horrified to learn that Oswalt no
longer possessed any internal organs so
save for his brain heart and lungs the
rest of him was empty later he was
interrogated and began raving about
Grand karcissist ions so much that the
doctor questioning Oswald attempted to
attack him breaking free of his
restraints Simon Oswalt amputated both
of the doctor's arms before he was
recontained by guards since then the
area of scp-2480 has been mostly quiet
but it still remains under the
foundation's close watch just in case
any anomalous happenings start up again
but if you're planning a tour of the
many haunted old houses of Massachusetts
we'd recommend maybe avoiding bodfell
Manor just to be safe Robert orlian and
his partner in crime John Streep zip
through the murky Waters of the
Louisiana Bayou on a speedboat these men
were dealers in the illicit but their
specialty was not any kind of Contraband
you'd probably recognize Orlean and
Streep Delton rare orchids a legally
poached from Air areas where they're
considered endangered and sold to
high-paying where plant collectors as
any seller or collector knows Rarity is
the Hallmark of value and what these two
men would encounter in the swamp that
day was truly One of a Kind the problem
for this pair of greedy opportunists is
that only one of them would live to tell
the tale and thanks to the SCP
Foundation the other wouldn't remember
it for long that's what happens when you
have a dangerous run-in with a certain
mean green swamp dwelling creature that
doesn't take kindly to unwanted visitors
and no we're not talking about a
crocodile Orlean and Streep continued
through the swamp keeping their Keen
eyes out for the flash of light blue
that had give away the orchids they were
seeking little did they know from the
murky Darkness between the Reeds a pair
of big yellow eyes were watching them
back they were Intruders in a stranger's
land threats just like the bad man they
would need to be dealt with accordingly
or a grim history would repeat itself
the boat came to a halt as the two
poachers finally saw one of the rare
flowers they were looking for arising
out of the muck orlian leap from the
boat and began waiting towards his prize
the flower would fetch him and his
partner a pretty penny if they could get
it back in good condition the Motions
were so well practiced for Orleans so
automatic that he didn't even notice
something was moving through the waters
towards him Gators and snakes were an
occupational hazard for people like
Orlean he kept a revolver holster just
below his shoulder as a precaution but
the thing about to kill him was unlike
anything he'd ever faced before just as
his careful fingers curled around the
orchid's stem Orly and heard Streep
screaming from the boat he was
frantically pointing at something just
beyond Orlean emerging from the Reeds
orlian turned and felt his jaw falling
open in horror at the side of it at
first it seemed almost like a
waterlogged corpse thick matted black
hair heavy with grease and muddy Bog
Water teeming with parasitic swamp life
her skin was green and bumpy like that
of a toad dripping with viscous green
sweat that seemed like it could only be
the byproduct of rot but those eyes
those big yellow amphibian eyes they
were alive as they were inhuman this
creature wasn't a corpse it was
something else entirely her body cleared
the water standing at Orleans height now
and facing him eye to eye she was naked
her dignity preserved by her long tangle
of hair her body was human shaped except
for her freakishly long thin limbs her
belly appeared visibly bloated or
engorged like a woman in the mid stages
of pregnancy Orlean had never smelled
something so foul in his entire life
which was mostly and wading through
swamps and bogs she smelled like death
itself Streep was screaming for Orlean
to climb back into the boat but Orlean
knew it was already too late he reached
for his holstered pistol but before he
could clear leather the creature let out
a horrific guttural Hawking noise and
spewed a stream of black goo onto
Orleans face it was hot sticky and foul
tasting like a kind of tar rendered from
corpses it plastered his open mouth and
nose shut and began to suffocate him he
tried desperately to clawed his face and
tear the offending substance away but
all that succeeded in doing was getting
his fingers stuck while orlian
suffocated and streaks screamed
terrified obscenities from the boat the
creature just watched and smiled through
rotten teeth it was nice to see them
Panic just like the bad man who'd come
before they were in the wrong they
deserved this Orleans soon realized that
nothing he could do would save himself
he'd spent his life in a dangerous
profession and been lucky until now but
the reaper catches up with everyone
eventually the last thing he saw as the
world went black was this creature this
swamp woman waiting towards him through
the water with a hungry look at her eye
she grabbed him on either side of his
face and just held him there what was
that sound was it fizzling like
something was burning or even melting
she just kept staring and smiling with
those awful rotten teeth Robert orlian
went to sleep in her hands and never
woke up back on the boat a desperate
John Street was watching a scene that if
it wasn't for the later intervention of
the SCP Foundation would haunt him until
his dying day he watched his partner
undergo a process that was somewhere
between rotting and melting he withered
away in the swamp woman's hands
degrading into thick black sludge that
she drank through her thirsty skin as
much as it pained him to leave his
friend behind Streep knew that there was
no saving him now all he could possibly
do was escape with his own life he
pulled the ripcord on the boat's motor
and tore his way back to the nearest
Township the shape of the nightmarish
swamp woman shrinking in the distance
behind him when he ran into the local
police station half mad with grief and
fear screaming about the monster that
had killed his friend in the swamp the
police understandably detained him for
further questioning when his criminal
history as a poacher was flagged up on
the database it became clear he probably
wasn't leaving for a while that's when a
foundation agent embedded in the
department passed a memo about the
case's strangeness up the chain of
command and a covert mobile task force
was soon dispatched to the swamp in
order to locate and capture the
anomalous creature that Streep had
claimed took his friend's life after a
few days of searching the swamp woman
was captured by the foundation and
redesignated as
cp811 before being delivered back to a
nearby containment site luckily for
foundation disinformation agents the
cover story was practically gift wrapped
for them on this one it had been a
dispute between two hardcore criminals
and as the saying goes there's no honor
among Thieves Streep had murdered Orlean
over a pay cut dispute and thrown him
into the swamp where his body was eaten
by Gators a few falsified records and
implanted memories later and the
foundation was free to do what it
pleased with scp-811 but the swamp woman
would prove to be full of surprises and
contradictions while designated as
Euclid the containment procedures for
the creature were rather extensive for
its own benefit like a lot of creatures
who'd never existed in captivity before
it had very specific needs in terms of
its artificial habitat the foundation
needed to be on top of everything from
the pH levels of its soil acidity to the
optimal temperatures and humidity levels
of its containment chamber built to
resemble the creature's natural swamp
habitat the swamp woman is mostly
non-aggressive to Foundation staff but
certain precautions need to be taken in
order to ensure everyone's safety around
her while she's largely humanoid her
internal physiology vastly differs from
that of humans her veins and digestive
system are non-functional she consumes
her prey by melting it into black sludge
with a highly caustic secretions of her
skin before absorbing it back through
her pores the waste material collects in
her stomach which he then expels
voluntarily through an action similar to
vomiting this is often used offensively
or in hunting prey as the unfortunate
Robert orlian found out as a result
people working in 811's containment
chamber need to do so in pairs and wear
heavily sealed hazmat suits for obvious
safety reasons the creature also proved
to be surprisingly intelligent while
well not a genius by any means it was no
mere mindless animal the swamp woman had
an intellect and communication skills on
par with your average feral child the
one that had been brought up and
socialized in a relatively normal home
before being turned loose and
experiencing a decline in its mental and
Social Development her words have a
childlike construction to them as though
English is inter native language and
she's still in the very early stages of
learning it she gave herself a name I
and began to cooperate well with
Foundation staff in exchange for having
her needs met since being brought into
containment she's made a number of
requests these include some requests
that have been denied by the foundation
such as the regular provision of bovine
prey for its chamber and a variety of
fish from its native environment to make
it feel more at home however there are
some requests that the foundation has
approved like a wooden hairbrush and a
d-class in a hazmat suit entering the
Room daily in order to help wash her
hair often bogged down by the frequency
at which her skin produces thick caustic
oils in one particularly strange request
she asked for a turtle and a hazmat suit
to act as a companion in her containment
chamber as she reacted negatively to the
idea of having Turtles as food sadly
this was one of the denied requests
scp-811 was also involved in a few
cross-tests with other anomalies leading
to curious results after realizing just
how dangerous scp-811 secretions could
be Foundation researchers naturally
floated the idea of using it on scp-682
in its seemingly endless termination
experiments a sample of 682's Flesh was
successfully decayed by the dangerous
mucus so a larger quantity collected
over a number of months was then sprayed
all over the Beast it managed to reduce
682's body mass by 27 percent melting
its way through the covered flesh down
to the bone
however at that point it was unable to
Decay further and as cp682 soon returned
back to its normal State who could have
possibly seen that coming right however
a much more interesting and enlightening
cross test occurred with
scp-978 the desired camera if you
haven't already seen our video on the
desired camera it's pretty much exactly
what the name suggests a Polaroid camera
that reveals the deepest desire of its
subject and the foundation decided to
test it on a large number of staff and
anomalies one of those being
scp-811 when a photograph was taken of
scp-811 just staring at the camera the
resulting photo depicted a human woman
with the same height build and facial
features as scp-811 braiding yellow
ribbons into her hair and wearing a blue
sundress the attending researchers felt
this raised an interesting question were
they looking at an aspiration towards
Humanity from scp-811 was this a
yearning to return to what had been
before there was only one way to find
out conduct an interview with the
creature itself when the interview began
the researchers pressed 811 on some of
her earliest memories one of the key
details she shared was regarding a
mysterious man whom she claimed came to
her before she'd look like she did now
back when her skin was soft and pink the
bad man he injected something into her
arm and whatever it was it changed her
mutated her took away her precious
Humanity the first thing she remembered
feeling after that was an all-consuming
hunger and then melting and devouring
the one who changed her destroying any
possible answers as to who he was or why
he did it in the process it was a story
of victimization and dehumanization so
cruel and upsetting that researcher
watchtel an assistant researcher
attending the interview actually threw
up later debriefing interview news
revealed it was because he had a
daughter of roughly the same age with
long dark hair if scp-811 has any
parents herself we may never know such
is the strange tragedy of scp-811
whether you wish to call her by her
number a nickname like the swamp woman
or herself given name of I will likely
never know who she was before as not
even she knows now it is an unsettling
reminder that all of our grasps on
Humanity are looser than you think
sometimes all it takes is one chance
encounter to change who you are
completely what is your favorite word
think about it for a moment think real
hard write it down in the comments
posted for everyone else to see how many
letters does it have how many syllables
say it aloud how does it sound how does
it feel on your tongue really really
think about it now make sure you keep
that word in mind it's important and
we'll come back to it later for now it's
time to talk about
scp-3449 look there's really nothing any
special about this one it wasn't even
important enough to be mentioned with
the other info hazards it's not an evil
talking toaster that's for sure
scp-3449 appears to just be a standard
spiral notebook not book it's supposed
to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark
blue cover it's safe class and it's
stored in the standard
standard containment Locker insight 19.
there aren't any other containment
requires but testing is currently
underway to determine
um I think it's meant to be determined
long-term containment requirements oh
this is a mess anyway this item and its
anomalous power is actually considered
so inconsequential that researchers have
explored the possibility of putting it
on the anomalous items log a place where
items too useless to warn to full file
ends up geez how do you misspell up that
badly it's two letters supposed to be
two letters how did you work Z into that
they aren't even close to each other on
keyboard
man anyway the notebook contains mostly
blank pages some are torn and only six
contain actual writing but due to the
formatting of the ridding the text
consisting mainly of diary entries is
almost unreadable this is due to
synaptical errors random capitalization
and rampant imp spellings great You
misspelled misspellings
how cute apparently all attempts to
correct these misspellings fail or even
lead to additional misspellings this
anomalous effect extends to anyone
attempting to write yep that was spelled
r-i-g-h-t anyone attempting to write
about
scp-3449 including the script for this
video apparently there are no further
notable Anonymous proper tests are
ongoing though those with any inquiries
about testing scp-3449 should contact
lead researcher Nick Lowe gerdinell The
Notebook which was misspelled even worse
this time impressive was first recovered
by MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots after a series of info
hazardous and Cognito hazardous
phenomenon were discovered in the
Pittsburgh Metroid area The Source
seemed to be a storage unit filled with
anomalous items and scp-3449 was a mogus
I think that's meant to be among them
the storage unit was registered to a man
by the name of Edward salzbro currently
designated as porpoise of Interest 4335
that's the end of that thanks for
watching the video folks now go check
out oh wait there's more phenomenal
let's keep going apparently that version
of the file was an older one let's check
the next one and see if that's any more
useful oh oh oh my it appears that the
updates here are actually quite
extensive okay let's give this another
try
scp-3449 is a Euclid class SPC kept in
the humanid containment cells of site
19. items affected by ant are kept in
standard store eggs lockers for safe
class anomalous objects at the same site
the primary reason for this shift is
that
scp-3449 has changed its object of
designation it is no longer the spiral
notebook it is now a 34 year old
Caucasian man known as Edward sells bro
formerly known as Person of Interest
4335 he is believed to be the creator of
the as well as other objects found in
the storage looker in Pittsburgh
Foundation Personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects
created by Mr sellsberg though success
has been limited on this front that was
cute
scp-3449's analogous abilities manifest
onto both Edward himself and all the
objects created by Him ridding about him
or any of these objects will result in
synaptical errors arbitrary
capitalization tunes and Rampart imp
smellings attempts to revise or correct
the writing will either fail to remove
the errors or create new errors it
appears that the anomalonymous effects
of
scp-3449 proper are more severe than
that of the ones caused by his anomalous
objects MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots apprehended as CP 3449 in
his apartment just outside of Pittsburgh
he appeared to be in an advanced state
of disorientation and dehydration
records collected by the mobile task
force found that Mr selberg had not left
his apartment in over 10 days which
would account for his dire health
conditions Salzburg did not communicate
with mambas of the mobile task force but
did not reset arrest and subsequent
containment either okay okay these
spellings are rough but I'm going to try
and power through I am a professional
and we're almost there the following is
the full lug of items obtained from
scp-3449 Storage look car that also
exhibit his anomalous effects The
Notebook as already discussed the pages
are either blank torn or illegible
salzburg's computer files saved on this
device include spreadsheets dealing
personal finances ideals for products
and an unfinished horror novel that is
almost unratable due to the poor quality
of its writing grocery list had only two
written items Booter was spelled with
only one t and medication which was
spelled medication a planner last entry
was dated two weeks before containment
and believed to contain reminders to
perform various chores however a mixture
of or handwriting and word choice allows
for other interpretations and finally Mr
salzberg's cell phone Foundation
researchers were also able to collect
the call logs in hopes of further
tracking salzburg's pre-containment
activities the last three calls which
were all made on the same day two weeks
before contentment dialed different
numbers only one of which was in use the
foundation made contact with the
receiver of said call who had no
knowledge of
scp-3449 and claimed that they did not
answer the call lead researcher Nick
Lowe gerdanell conduced the first in
interview with
scp-3449 shortly after his capture when
he entered the interview chambri he
found that
scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his had in his hands rocking
back and forth in what appeared to be
apparent distress he then begun looking
down into his lap in twiddling his
thumbs like a child Nick Lowe engaged
him in a calm and polite tone addressing
him as
scp-3449 the autumnly made eye contact
with Dr gerdinell but he didn't respond
and instead continues starring at him as
gurnanau axed further Quest Tunes
Salzburg simply did an answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the
questions with simple gestures gerd now
asked whether Salzburg was making
products for his business to which he
smiled and shuck his head gernel then
asked Salzburg whether he could speak or
not or if it was merely a choose on his
part unsurprisingly Salzburg offered no
explanation and the interview came to a
close shortly afterwards tests are still
ongoing to find out if salzburg's
inability to spack or communicate come
as a result of his anomalous traits or
if this is simply a result of epiphonia
a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to Spike
tests have confirmed that sellsburg does
have all the organs required for
vocalization but s appears to not use
them for the tests are required alright
there we have it that was a complete
nightmare to read thanks to
scp-3449's anomalous effects but at
least it's over now
now go check out wait there's more
another update to the file good okay
all right let's go take a look oh I see
this is a lot more dangerous than I
thought I suppose I better read on
scp-3449 Hayes been upgraded to ketter
class anomal
scp-3449-a the new designation for
Edward salzburger is to be kept in a
high security Hazmat containment in site
19. the inanimate anomalous possessions
of Edward Salzburg are to be keeped in
standard object containment any reports
written on scp-3449 must be rotten by
Popple who have been exposed to it for
less than seven days in order to keep
the files raidable to prevent this
infectious info has marred from spread
further the number of people allowed to
interact with this anomaly is kept
relatively small and consists of those
that have already been exposed at some
point or another this includes 05-8 MTF
Epsilon 6. Dr teller's research team
some additional Personnel selected for
xpc-3449 research and Personnel chosen
to update
scp-3449 documentation some additional
Personnel selected for xpc 3449 research
and Personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while Edward
sellsberg and his personal effects are
chronically locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered
contained Research into the sprod of
scp-3449's effects the vectors for
transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects
are now taupe priority for all in Loved
Before this whole thing gets out of hand
further research has taught the
foundation that not only are Salzburg
and his items powerful info hazards
their enemless effects appear to be able
to infect these who experienced them
permanently initially it will a prayer
that writing quality only degrades when
the subject is actually writing about
scp-3449 itself but over time they'll
come to the frightening realization that
it actually affects their riffing as a
whole the effect also progresses in its
similarity over time eventually
rendering the victim's ability to write
legible sentences completely displayed
the initial anomalous effects of
scp-3449 were discovered when MTF
Epsilon 6 writes their field reports on
the Mater and found it littered with
synaptical error random capitalization
and rampant in plillings similar errors
appearing in the initial fail about
scp-3449 only serve to reaffirm this
observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of
scp-3449 effects when the village idiots
field reports concerning other
solomonies came in with equally
atrocious writing attempts to correct
this writing simply led to more
mustaches and frustration on part of
Team soon after a Reese stretcher named
Dr Teller who'd since track and ove were
the
scp-3449 case and his team found that
they were experienced to timbler issues
they couldn't just make the blurreds
happen no matter how hard they
constraint traded they forgot spellings
they couldn't make hand move in the
manner they waited to in order to form
the wards even the most intelligent and
articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young children on
page but didn't stop there wasn't long
before researchers who'd never worked on
the
scp-3449k started to exhibit these same
suspicious errors in own writing the
foundation didn't know how but this
through likeness was starting to spread
with people's abilities to Reich
degrading across the entire Foundation
that's when a foundation web trawler
picked up same thing even more
distrobbing Global literacies seemed to
be taking a dive The Telltale synaptical
error random to capitalization and
rampant illingness spellings tickling up
everywhere and for everyone and the end
of writing would be one thing but
scp-3449 doesn't stop there now that's
just the beginning Morse code go next
then pictograms not long for sign
language become hopeless scrambled
communication
breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move right
hands Gall goes calls codes Lasko his
voice talking gets hurt remember Fabrics
word
think about it say it loud when
scp-3449 done when everyone infected
you'll never say again nobody will ever
say okay
now go check out Minecraft world
Destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in The Crucible and
scp-055 anti-meme unknown for more
mind-bending anomalies from the SCP
Foundation